foreign
two
good morning it's Monday May 8th
beautiful summer day out here in Los
Angeles California
[Music]
wish you wherever you guys are a happy
happy Monday afternoon thank you very
much
today we have prepared what I believe to
be
and this is a rare exception for us a
pretty good show
you know what I mean
this is going to be one of the good I
don't know if I agree you don't like
Today's Show
the bad one I just don't I don't have
that level of confidence well let's see
let the people decide
yes so uh thank you everybody for being
here hope everyone had a good weekend
you know
I'm feeling pretty accomplished as a dad
because last night
I went through the horrible experience
of sleep training
young Bruce brewbrew as I'm calling now
uh Bruce my youngest son Brew
that's cute I like brewbrew we cycle
through a lot of nicknames for him yeah
bro and um I slit he had a real he was
really bad at sleeping through the night
and so I decided listen I gotta do this
and if you guys don't know what sleep
trending is
it's like the worst thing ever I mean I
went to bed feeling like the biggest
piece of [__] ever but
what you do is you put them in the crib
you say okay you know love you kisses
I'll be back and then you walk out
and they just he freaks the frick out I
mean
this kid has never been left alone like
that too so it's like
sounds like he's dying and he's reaching
for you whenever you go there jumping
it's very it's very hard
but I did that so you got um
you go sit out on on the room next door
you come back every five minutes he
freaks out
and I did that for like an hour you add
a little extra time
you know each time five ten minutes you
know
and eventually he gets so exhausted from
just crying and freaking out and he's
tired already this happened at 11. he
had already been sleeping for three or
four hours
[Music]
to where he starts to wear out and then
he's sitting there like nodding off it
breaks my heart I would go in there and
I was like he's got to be asleep and
he's just sitting there silently almost
like PTSD holding his his like teddy
bear
and nodding off like this
like a little Junkie
in the cutest way possible Right like a
like a cute junkie like a cute little
very cute junkie yeah like heroin chic
baby
heroin cheese baby
and so um speak baby you go he's got to
be sleeping and then I go back I come
back 10 minutes later he's got to be
sleeping and he's sitting there again
still nodding off I'm like oh my God so
anyway after about an hour I was able to
lay him down
cover him with his blanket and and he
finally he fell asleep on his own
and he slept through the night too
you know probably fell asleep at 12 and
woke went all the way through the night
so
what king I don't think he's ever done
that
so this is my new life I gotta be doing
this every night with him and uh
God I felt I felt so bad when I went to
bed but he was happy to see me this
morning
you feel like he's gonna hate me forever
now
Katie will never forgive me hi
um
hello I also wanted to add that was the
first time ever that we slept through
the night ever yeah
so he got a good night's sleep and
so did we
there that is huh
ah
yeah yeah
I did this I did the same thing to
Theodore but you know
we've been putting it off with Brew brew
for some reason but you know now now
he's old enough
so that was you know that was that
thank you though Theodore
yeah he tried to say [__] to me uh on
Sunday Ela
Teddy
oh she's gone already
she's out
wait you are there
what's happening can you hear me
were you talking to me
don't worry about it
yeah I was saying that I was saying
Teddy was trying to say [__] To Me on on
Sunday but whatever
yes okay
thank you for backing me up on that one
but yeah so I mean but otherwise the the
weekend was good you guys have any
interesting uh weekend
rehearsal baby
for the big day big day
May 14th coming 13th
I was 14th well they did you sell out of
tickets there we have 50 tickets left
okay so we're almost there so if they
show up on the 14th I mean as long as
they bought a ticket who cares yeah yeah
it's all good yeah
troubadour or Roxy which one are we at
Roxy or at the Roxy live at the Roxy on
May 14th 13th
14th at the at the Troubadour sure
yeah uh some exciting news actually e
lacline
just posted her first Vlog she's
completing her transition
to be coming she is a full-blown
influencer now
and I'm gonna like it
because I I would love it if I could
but this is a like a love button if you
go over to the ELA Ethan and Eli Channel
Ela is going to be co-opting this hit
that subscribe button dude right
smash that button smash that button and
uh Eli you're flexing in your car pretty
heavily in the first frame I don't know
it's like damn girl we were out on the
street and it was super windy so I was
like we gotta sit in the car okay you
look good though in it like okay what
which car is that again I can't tell
it's like Zach with his uh Rolex
um yeah ela's co-opting this channel you
guys are gonna be posting like how
frequently are you you and Ila made this
together right
I mean Lena
Scott and edited everything
hey
[Applause]
I think we're gonna try once a week
that's fun so if you guys you guys
should check out Ela vlog01
so you're planning 99 Max I'm assuming
because it's zero one that's what
happens yeah that's gonna be a big
moment here let's watch a minute this is
crazy
I think I'm gonna bring back the Vlogs
on the Ethan Anila Channel which is
probably where you're watching this now
so uh welcome back
I think this is gonna be a new thing I'm
kind of trying out
um I got Lena with me recording I mean
I'm the camera
we love them oh damn
so you guys get all these fit revisit
creepers this is my type of content yeah
this is definitely for the girlies if
they want yo the outfit's fire what the
hell when did you wear that one
I actually wanted to get that one but I
was like I did recently a two-piece pink
one so oh I think that's cool I'm gonna
time it out
[Music]
what do we do with that puffer uh notice
so this one we shot on Saturday and you
will see what we did with it oh okay
okay
yeah nice
you could just kind of lay down wherever
you are and
I was thinking about you you would love
it
puffer fish
keemstar likes it a puffer Puffer
and then there's also BTS in the office
send help shirt is called the Howie
Mandel shirt
sin pretty much
sure starting it up oh hell yeah I just
started I just started vlogging oh
recently as well I feel you it's hard
it's awkward hi everybody yeah
um yeah we see that actually I came here
to say thank you wait why no thank you
for supporting there's a part where you
say hi to the crew
my Vlog no
no don't film me no hey guys that's me
by the way
the probably will be the most watched
part of this vlog
sorry that's stupid sorry though it's
not that
my Vlog no
so yeah uh congratulations I'm excited
for you guys as a project here and and
Eli I we all love to see a queen
spreading her wings
that is so true
okay
it's fun that you're both working on it
too and great job Lena edited that up
that's awesome
thank you so much it's been so much fun
really yeah I'm having a blast doing it
yay that's awesome she was super nervous
because she watched the channel for
years and so
making this video she's nervous but she
sent to ELA and he listed it was really
good and she was really excited so yeah
you nailed it it's awesome good job
also since you're here you'll just give
one little last shot at the top here
Howie Mandel did a shoot for Teddy fresh
and Sam who's here
um
Sam I guess would you say you kind of
directed this were you I mean you were
there uh yeah I was spearheaded this
yeah
it was awesome I love Howie he was that
was his first time modeling ever which I
was very shocked by you would think like
early over his career he would have
modeled something but
no this was his modeling debut wow it
was so much fun he killed it dude he is
seriously I love how we Mendel step
aside Heidi Klum who are you never worn
anything interesting Howie enter stage
look at here look at this cool one
bald is in this is from uh today because
we you guys shot a few sets
um he has this crazy
thing in his Studio I saw it when I did
his podcast
where it IT projects a 3D hologram of
you it's super crazy and it just looks
so real it looks it is so great they
when I went to scout the location they
did one of me and it tripped me out so
hard it's like it's really it's very
realistic yeah so I guess he's like an
angel investor and he's letting the guys
use his office because he's the same as
that we've uh literal Angel yeah we've
gone over that angel come on
he looks awesome why why'd you have to
go that hard Howie there's no reason for
that
none
yeah come on tally Mandel ladies and
gentlemen Give It Up
to Uncle Howie America's uncle
mail for Sam as well good job Sam are
great thank you
love it good job everybody
good work team what's that Zucker that
suck sound bite good work team
I'm the meat Chef nobody no no not that
one
uh there's one during a
nice job team thank you Kim we gotta
find that here thank you Cam you saved
my life nice job because I hear
flandering
check this out you guys
this is important stuff
nice job team
that's it
oh so I this was like a story he made
because he would love the new glasses so
he was saying nice job team nice job
team
that's the most affirmation they'll ever
hear from their boss nice job team
and you could tell he meant it boy
that goes a long way you got to be
surprised we actually have a little
thing about the Zuck today
good transition oh yeah zuck's been
doing some Kung Fu Fighting some karate
sure uh since we're on the topic yeah
zucky boys been in a jiu jitsu
tournament beating the [__] out of
people he's 38 he won Gold man they let
his ass win
he won gold and silver medals at his
first Brazilian good
dude if you're right if you're wrestling
Zuck you let him win
that man owns Hawaii it's like come on
Zuck said he took up an interest in the
sport early on in the pandemic and
posted his win on Instagram saying
competed in my first Jiu Jitsu
tournament and won some medals for the
gorilla Jiu Jitsu team whatever bro can
you just like why you gotta
look what this guy's doing
why you gotta show up to like a
community event and then also just like
ruin it for everybody like you're
already the richest guy in the world
just let them have their [__] fun
event like zuck's gotta come stunt on
them too
of course you won you probably have like
stem cells coursing through your you
know what I mean stem cells you've
probably got the best trainers in the
world you probably have titanium bones
not impressed
this dude doesn't need to know any
self-defense he can pay for all the
security in the world I think he just
wants to hurt people right that's uh my
takeaway
suck you baby huh yellow belt
cringe I don't know what that means
but you know what I mean it's like come
on Zuck come on suck you don't stop
trying to act like you're a normal human
being just [__]
go back to
doing that weird Hydro boarding with a
bunch of sunscreen on your face by
yourself meets now smoking these meats
here
here is a video of him grappling
compliments of TMZ who's great thank you
TMZ they always don't blame us
all right
is this full uh yeah
[Music]
you know when Zuck rolls up he's got his
own secret service it's like when the
president comes
he's like
I know you're dead and now I own you
[__]
[Music]
it's getting manhandled there
not everything has to be gay
but that being said okay
[Music]
you're getting comfortable
were those marks feet that just went I
can't tell if he's on top or on the
bottom but I could tell whoever's on the
bottom just orgasmed yeah they're giving
a lot of feet look at the feet the feet
feel bad okay wait what was that that
looked like brain damage wait why did
his feet do that that's so funny what
the [__] is that
that ain't no goddamn jujits who move
crisscross what
what the [__]
[Music]
[__]
[Applause]
oh that was Ducky on the bottom
your geese open he's got manhound bro
[Music]
so let me get this straight he we just
watched him get his ass kicked the
entire time and he won Gold Medal right
nobody kisses his ass ever
[Music]
he's arguing with the ref
he's like [__]
what a loser
but uh we'll always have this moment
right sakipu
where's them feeds
here he goes he's about to nut
ah Zach
where would we be without Fair lovely
Zuck
hey what was that
that was from the story last week
harmonic at the concert oh oh that was
him
down the street as jiu jitsu
so Friday we had um the accent coach on
yeah big big success there and a lot of
people
were kind of tickled by how that uh bit
turned out
um and there was a lot of people
debating if I made that that dark
Nathaniel klansman
on the spot or if I was reading from the
uh
the laptop and I found that conversation
pretty funny to me but before we get
here's the look of Horror
I watched that scene back and every time
Ian cut to Jack Jack I was just dying
because this man
like
he's just taking it all in he was being
a good sport not even a smile
I mean yes and like he's super focused
too
he's listening to your accent yeah I
think we're all super focused we're just
trying to hear the story
[Music]
what Ethan is going for
what Ethan sounds like hey come on you
would just you would like pull out these
really poetic phrases where I was like
where the [__] is that coming from like
at one point you described something
they went I don't like the rain I was
like damn beautiful life was live
it's just dead homies telling stories
through me
I'll have you know that Forrest Gump was
a great American
that's right he may not he may not be a
smart man but he does know what love is
you never know what you're going to get
um Ethan Shelby this looks just like
dirty Dom
somehow like Tom Shelby the most
handsome man alive when you merge him
with me he just looks [__] goofy as
hell you know what I mean I'll take any
handsome ass to it and just [__] his
[__] up
[Music]
I tell you man something just came
through me that afternoon
[Music]
sometimes walking through the forest
like okay yeah here we go again I got I
got buttoned already
people says I genuinely thought Ethan
was just reading a monologue that a crew
member sent to him or something the fact
that he improvised all that was actually
impressive
did you it would be more impressive in
my opinion that somebody was feeding me
a monologue
or that I was reading from chat GPT that
would be crazy well I I was I mean you
were so
you know well thought out with it you
know there was no pausing there was no
it came from some weird part of your
brain yeah it doesn't seem that uh
no you're you're great uh improv it had
an emotional structure it did it went
intro climax conclusion gave us
everything
well I don't know about you but
sometimes life is Stranger Than Fiction
that's why I don't read fiction too much
I just kind of live it all you know
read me a book said
that's too strange to work out that way
but I'll tell you when I walk through
life and I I think about all the strange
things happen to me I think well
it's not strange enough
like that one time grandpappy came back
to my house
[Music]
he told me he found some roadkill on the
street that man was a good old block we
ate man if that roadkill was fresh he
took it home it was up you know what it
is me
[Music]
but when he brought that road killing it
was like a good old like fresh deer just
a day old not too stinky but a little
good foreign
we brought that deer open brought that
in the kitchen lock Mama came out said
that deer stinking ground Peppa
Grand Papa got a little violent at times
when he drank his Budweiser
hmm
she knew better to talk to him like that
especially with his parent knife
he just Dad excuse me
I thought so uh somebody said there's a
whole debate I thought so too but
there's no way Chad should be two would
ever write a story involving incest and
murder
he's looking at his screen but his eyes
aren't moving at all
then occasionally he continues the story
while looking away from the screen he
also says things like Jeremiah and I
were real close like which isn't how
Chad gbt talks it's how Ethan's Southern
character talks what's your argument I
think he's actually making it up which
is insane
well thank you I'm glad uh you guys
enjoyed that
mm-hmm
yes
real nice
Bill Nye suck the first Rin during
spring
snowfalls sometimes feel like it's never
going to end
like to watch the snow melt away filled
the Creeks up
yes but when The Creeks fill up
sometimes
animals come out the green come out
[Music]
but there's one creature came out when
the Creeks rise I don't like to think
about that much but I will tell you
since you asked
[Music]
I never
are you are you in Earnest adjusting
that Dan
I just thought we'd be here for a while
so maybe I'm gonna take a little nap a
new member says cottage cheese put a
shot collar on Ethan please
[Music]
not a bad idea
it's kind of a fun idea
uh but anyway thank you guys uh and
shout out to Jack who endured that uh
also have some sad news just to tell you
guys that ela's not here anymore but
she posted about it the IVF transfer
didn't work
yeah
sucks boo she talks about it in the Vlog
too at the end
it really sucks and now we don't know
what to do because like we said seven
eggs one girl
and I guess we're not sure if we want a
three boys
I'm kind of of the mind that like
I don't know we're thinking about it we
don't know what to do now because if we
wanted to go for a girl it would be like
a whole another like three months of
intense medication and
operations of getting the eggs it's
really really
unpleasant for her
Dan are you a crane operator sounds like
you're at the dock like I'm trying
there's a lot of factors here with all
these monitors and things sticking out
and then I have this table over here I'm
very afraid of breaking something so
sounds like you're controlling one of
those claw machines at the arcade
Excavating perfect movements watch your
eyes I'm coming
yeah so I was sad man it's I really
thought it was gonna stick
Eli was talking about she kept getting
cramps in her feet which is apparently a
thing
you're pregnant you get cramps in your
feet I was like
okay
but she had her period like uh Saturday
night
that sucks but okay
you know what I mean it is what it is
everything works out
that's what mama said man God's plan is
a fun thing that's right
tell you what sometimes you just don't
see you coming
but you know when my little sister
passed away real young girl 12.
I looked up God I wonder what is God's
plan killed nice beautiful girl my
sister so lovely
where's God's plan in that I wondered
hmm
[Music]
God's plan
the only plan out here is the one
I'm making in the backyard put cement
over the body
uh yeah let's not get caught up okay but
let's get on to some fun stuff so thank
you guys
uh
we actually lots of love for the Crowder
button
we got some edits from fans here we go
there's Dan it actually kills me
that's it big modification that was a
great edit yeah Thanos snapped just
death to Dan button Dan I don't want to
hear that chair anymore well you are you
dumb
yeah
I
unplugged the light
unplug the light
like a little stinker no that doesn't
work either
um we also got
jumping a ramp a mobility scooter ramp
jump okay [__] go I knew there was
something worth getting out of bed for
jumping a ramp on a Mobility Scooter
this is [__] what I live for
down at the beach why not bro how much
little adjustments do you need
we've landed we've landed we've landed
we've landed
what are you doing
you know what we've seen a similar one
and what I love about it is how all
their [__] falls out Nigel testing out
his skills on the scooter oh
That's my boy if you need if you didn't
need one then he does for sure now
not your ID after this he's gonna need
one of those ones that he pushes with
mouth straws
the straw ones are badass Dan what do I
say wrong they go
it's sick high tech and amazing
yeah dude
we'll get him a nice one make sure he's
comfy luck the Supercar Nigel testing
out his skills on the scooter first of
all that ramp is pretty steep okay let's
not he was set up also that's no Gatsby
that ain't that ain't no Gatsby boy oh
yeah
oh this boy is [__] right now look at
that that is that ain't looking good to
me boy I love how all the [__] in the
basket Launches on his face
somehow the battery shoots out
that's the charger it's like he uh he
dropped the loot yeah
you know this is awesome because this is
something you expect like a 15 year old
to do but
this is like a grown man it seems like
which I like that about him
oh [__] bro
dude's gonna be blowing through straws
for a little while
there it is congratulations we love our
we love our scootered uh friends and
family don't we
test United skills on the scooter oh
yeah check out your skills on the
scooter
it's good
here let me try it
I think that the biggest piece of advice
is like the not pronouncing the ours
thing right like
he goes go like this
wave your finger around okay yeah all
together wedding ring and 22. gay
so okay lots of good stuff happening
here
I just noticed he's wearing fake Yeezys
in the video
how do you notice that Chet pointed it
out now what how can you tell
those are those are fake Yeezys you can
tell from this far away testing out his
skills on the scooter so in a sense he
had to come yeah how could you possibly
know that oh Zach can you tell
I mean I agree
wow blurry maybe but
I don't know
so what's the point of pointing that out
he deserves it for being broke
yeah
he's broken he's broken in his opposed
if it wasn't broke you get really use
these in a real scooter poser yeah if
you had really you have a real machine
like a Gatsby and now look you're going
through straws
[Laughter]
hey
holy brev
I think yes I
picky blinders
how do you say think I think yeah
I don't think it's pink I think I think
uh
so you got the hard arm broke so you say
but what how would you say Baroque
without the Hard Rock well he said you
only do the r if it's in front of a
vowel I was like boys don't tell me that
not crunching those numbers
are you thinking about it too much just
go with the vibe
[Music]
oh my God
you got me
no you ever heard of Jenna
I believe Janet did that scooter trick
once genocide
you guys want to get a good old American
moment here
always this I don't know what's the
event but there's lots of dirt
some kind of post I guess this is a good
old kind of bull riding thing
you know good old cowboy kinda
here we go guys
this is America my friends watch this
person here bye yo
oh [__] that's America wait I'm so
confused
well they this man was so desperate to
fly the American flag he jumped out of a
plane with a massive 30-foot Pole now I
don't know much about parachuting but
that does not seem like a good idea
look at this
so it's just
that's America
that's America he's fine oh he's fine
yeah of course so I mean he's a
professional
[Music]
has this long ride of America taste
[__] oh you can see him start to back
up like oh [__] and then it's too late
of course the American flag got a big
old long [__]
that's right I got swept up in it
[Music]
and then
boom
that's great huh
the rocks good stuff out there
that's America wasn't there some
shootings too over the weekend or I
believe so in Texas yeah
hell yeah brother
it's not good news they should have they
should just have like uh
I've got the solution
in Texas
there needs to be roaming paratroopers
with American flag parachutes and and
obviously ARS full body armor roaming
the skies because School shooters are
happening so frequently they will be
roaming the skies daily when there's a
report of a school shooting they jump
out of the plane armed like this so they
so they're on standby in the plane to
Circle always okay got it and they jump
out this is how they ascend on this on
the school right or the mall or whatever
of the shooter
take them out I mean why not that makes
as much sense as what we're doing yeah
no and since at least that's it's
something yeah that's that's a plan it's
not a great plan
kind of awful plan but me badass but
he's sick as [__]
it's the number one priority you know
after the last time
what was it where was all those kids got
murdered a couple teachers it was recent
where the police just sat there and
[__] didn't do anything
[Music]
I don't even know what to say about the
topic anymore frankly
there's nothing really more to say is
there
We're not gonna do anything about it so
this is just what we live with now it's
cool this is it
we need the real Team America
right patrolling the skies
hello citizens I heard somebody here at
fired off around
um I'm here to save y'all
[Laughter]
hell yeah it is
we need more guns
I'll tell you why Bob
the 300 million guns in America we've
got
if only we had more we'd be living in
safer country damn it
yeah
honestly it's too painful to even tune
in to this
my sister died in the hospital after a
month-long Battle of cancer this is the
bill they sent her let's [__] go
right now three hundred thousand new
charges 1.3 million
patience payment since last statement
that's a massive discount that's awesome
actually it's just dead delinquent
account but look they took off they cut
off what that's like over 70 percent
maybe they use honey this isn't my first
time
you know what's fun what's like
well it's not funny it's actually insane
the reason Healthcare is so [__]
expensive is because
the government or I assume some kind of
someone pays this bill
well I don't think from the insurance
company they like [__] get it down
super much when it's under insurance
that means she didn't have insurance or
something
no I'm saying if like the insurance pay
like a fraction of that yeah
yeah that's crazy
she's dead amount due by 527. uh she's
dead but the good thing about medical um
debt is it passes on right
um I know some states they make you
liable for agreeing to take on the debt
it's not awesome it's just alone it goes
on to your [__] kids bruh
isn't that that's the best I just I
don't know if it has to be agreed upon
beforehand that's the thing but agree to
that
sure I'll take that on I mean yeah
people would if it was for what reason
it's about the one it feels like their
parent or something
I'm saying typically errors are not held
responsible for deceased persons medical
debt unless they have explicitly agreed
to assume responsibility or if the
spouse resides that's what you said the
property state
big differences
I thankfully have not had to deal with
anything like that so I don't I don't
know how that works you know it's so
dysfunctional I mean it's so disgusting
we are so depraved we are so apathetic
we are so [__] conservatives are
they're demons I don't know what to say
you know I I do conservatives even act
in good faith like are they even are
they just cynical self-serving Freaks
Like genuinely I don't mean that to be
divisive but I do think that every
conservative is a demon right
because like
I don't mean to be divisive but I love
that because I just don't understand how
any
one can conclude
that this is good because according to
conservatives this is good this is a
functioning system
with guns functioning system
but that but they obviously can't really
believe that right
so it just makes me wonder why like they
all worship or and Rand what's her name
the Atlas Shrugged einrand who's who's
whose philosophy is get yours and [__]
everyone else
and they think that that's awesome
and Noble
I'll tell you what man just give me an
AR appointment where to drop
I'm here boys whoa
oh [__] joke clown World idiots
by the way this dude just got a she's
got a hospital bill for fifty thousand
dollars
good luck with that
wooy
I ain't paying that [__] until it gets
hot in Texas
yes sir can anyone explain what the [__]
is going on here
I think love sent me this and I've been
captivated by it what's going on here we
weren't able to find anything
oh no I know a little bit about these
people okay what like there's a whole
[__] underground of tick tock battles
that are just insanely massive and I've
noticed like there's um
they branded [__] uh like countries
versus countries I don't know if you
guys seen that on Tick Tock lately I
have not seen anything like this one
I've only seen Terry Joe do it once yeah
but these people do this on a day-to-day
basis it's crazy but
what's the battle
is it so well I don't know the the
specific one but it seems Seems like
they're just um they they hype it up
beforehand and then they like set a date
and they just battle each other these
are like pre-planned and it's battle
house what's the battle you're competing
for donations right there okay yeah so
it's diamonds being donated
um and the one who wins or it's like a
way to incentive donations yeah okay so
I I'm assuming these both must be pretty
big tick Talkers in their countries
that's the weird part they're not
massive okay well apparently there's
like
there's a million are there there's 800
000 people watching this why 800 000
people watching this
okay now watch this
a hundred diamonds is one dollar right
uh at least in our currency nope
it's more advanced so I'm gonna bring up
a calculator it's super Advanced okay so
here we go you got to do conversions
here it is guys
oh I'm so sick
okay now
just put this in context
oh it's a little bit cut off
so I can't see this but it looks like
it's already at 5 million
and yeah no no I think it was 25 million
dude there's another digit right here
there's there was 50 million of that
that's just the Border it's 5 000
when it gets smaller dude I'm not I'm
not kidding look Jesus maybe there's
five million wow so a hundred thousand
equals 550 so what so that's fifty
thousand dollars already
go
I just don't get it the whole country
everybody in their country a million
people just donating is it like uh is it
like you know nationalists like it's
like which which country is better kind
of thing that's one John Rocket but also
uh when I went to this guy's Tick Tock I
think it had a bunch of religious things
so I think um
um he's some kind of a religious guy too
which might reduce the numbers
explicitly here
I'll do this I mean anyone out there
want to battle me
this battle
[Music]
Terry Joe
did Terry Joe get a ton of donations
when uh I didn't see anything like this
so I I see the promo for this event uh
and so it's uh the UAE versus Saudi
Arabia oh Rich [__] yeah so the
guy on the left is Saudi which you can
tell from the flag hanging behind it and
then I'm seeing on this promo I believe
it's yeah it says yeah it says UAE
actually so yeah okay so they're just
like here's oh
okay now now they're about to hit a
threat homie here on on uh Saudi Arabia
is winning this is a very exciting
moment yeah and he just hit
um let's see he just hit 10 million 10
million yeah wait what's the crunch the
numbers on 10 million
that would be
a hundred right if a hundred thousand is
550. there would be fifty thousand
dollars no no no no
hold on hold on no 100k
and put it into the calculator
it's no no no no no no that doesn't make
sense hold on just do this
10 million divided by a hundred thousand
how much is that
it's definitely 50k because it sets it
in the calculator in the I put it I put
it okay I'm not going to argue with the
calculator
it's the calculator dude
[Music]
it's exciting though I don't know what's
going on but I'm in it
yeah
[Music]
oh this [__] on the bottom is like I
guess when you buy fit it does
a little Graphics someone said that line
is like 200. come on yeah
[Music]
trying to get left in the dust
broke ass who's the guy on the right
yeah Emirates loser broke idiot Saudi
Arabia forever
Saudi Arabia forever
[Applause]
We Salute You uh King uh what's the
king's name I think uh MB yes or Yes
sounds like whatever that sounds like
sounds like a irritable bowel syndrome
IBS
okay wait he's not the king yet actually
I think he like kind of de facto runs
things but
yeah he's just the Crown Prince he will
be the king everybody is the king of all
cases the king is Solomon bin Abdul Aziz
so he's taking the L
and his son is rising up
taking the L meaning getting old
dying of old age our shot is pointing
out that some some of these numbers are
likes to apparently calculates likes too
what does that mean white I don't really
know
that's a big difference between likes
and donations so homie here is now at
uh 26 million let's just skip to the end
and see where they end up
how are you going to see all the Nuance
of how the match played out well here it
is here it ends uh uh shout out to the
kingdom of IBS
man
uh versus the kingdom of uh slavery of
uh Southeastern Asia slavery
love the golf uh love the Gulf States if
you can't tell
oh what they ran out of energy
oh he sees the writing look it's three
counting down at the top he knows he's
[__]
game over yeah nice try idiot
[Music]
dude you knew you won
why are you sad you just got 300 million
[__] dingoes because he lost
obvious
hello
yes
[__] yes oh now that it's almost to a
million live viewers
940 000 live viewers
God I just it's so incredibly weird I do
not I just don't get it
I don't get it
why oh he's got a picture of him oh he
put in his pocket damn owned [__]
the guy on the right note is getting
into these uh kind of uh rabbit holes uh
Middle Eastern Tick Tock is so massive
or arabic speaking Tech talk okay so so
it must there's a million people
watching this now
that has to be like our live stream
record
yeah it's pretty crazy
a million people watching live yeah
that's that's insane
so there it is congrats to our to our
guys here Pierce competitors the winner
ended up with 40 million
uh diamonds things which is 200k USD if
everything is donations the lights does
throw it throw it up in there a little
bit
okay so 200 200 000. you guys know the
funny thing is
Ed Sheeran yeah I [__] saw it
um
Ed Sheeran had a 5.5 live viewers God
[__] damn wait hold on hold on hold
up
too many people talking at once love
what were you gonna say first uh I was
gonna say the funny thing is that Tick
Tock keeps 66 so what I'm telling you is
66. yeah yeah
I'm giving it the 200 000 is just the
personal take so what they all would
what they actually made was six hundred
and twenty thousand dollars but Tick
Tock takes uh 66.
which is funny does Apple get a coat of
that too if it's donated through an
iPhone I don't know how did you
calculate that because there's a
calculator online that
um so for 40 million coins is total USD
600k Tick Tock keeps 400 000 and
influencer keeps 200k what the [__] dude
Tick Tock needs to start paying people
[__] this man the payment that they pay
people is just pathetic and they're
making so much Goddamn money
you know when I'm scrolling these days
it's like add every other video
it's time to start paying up [__]
there's also limits that you can only
withdraw a thousand dollars per day
which is also weird oh that's super
scammy too yeah
well now uh Amy you were saying
something about Ed Sheeran he has the
record for the most uh live views I
believe on Tick Tock with 5.5 million
what
5.5 million yeah he was hammering on
music performance
what are your thoughts on that camera
I'm pissed they ruined my day the weeks
off to the wrong start now do we have a
recording of that I'd love to uh relive
the magic if possible let's see
the magic the dark the
dark arts right there dude
I got this cat edge up still by my desk
they remind me every day
tomato and chap that I'm haunted by this
man
well that's a [__] weird Little slice
of the internet I mean kind of blew my
mind
here's a new chair for Dan okay this is
fire
in the theme of America Dan's not here
but
this is this
can you blow can you power it with a
straw
dude that thing is freaking awesome I
can't even get a hate
I'm sure those miniguns actually fire
too
oh those miniguns for sure fire live
ammunition
oh that Glides nice it is So Graceful
right
So Graceful
the minigun should be controlled by the
straw
went wrong blow
taking y'all out
umbrella American flag
there it is
Erica Ingenuity baby
did you find that Ed Sheeran One no I'm
looking at it this blog post is from
tick tock's official page but I'm not
seeing it uh
still looking though yeah young gravy
put out a video where a music video it's
got me and him making out
okay well he's gonna have to clear that
with my attorneys
this was not cleared for the record
let's go
here's the post
is there music in it
oh yes there is
oh his God
his own video had the video the audio
removed
that's so weird that must have just
happened
this man got copyrighted on his own damn
video
wait where's the where was the blip of
me
it'll show up on the side okay okay
shout out
young gravy
I'm feeling it
all right that's all the fun stuff now
let's get to the serious stuff Mr
BEAST's new video
yes sir I tied up in FBI agent I
recreated Willy Wonka's Chocolate we are
currently surrounded by countless shots
this is the largest stadium in the world
so the last time uh and first of all let
me just preface I always have to say
Jimmy's a great guy he is a great guy he
does so much good things and honestly
the one that really won me over was when
he stuck up for his Homie Chris or yeah
Chris
she is by the way so Chris
is trans
and as a she I think ultimately uh she
decided uses she her pronouns
yeah I think so I don't know I don't
know if she said that made that
clarification but
yeah let's use I spoke to her a little
bit oh very fast and asked that's nice
what was the uh preferred you know
I hope she's doing well
I don't uh yeah
it's [__] up I mean it's [__] up to
Tran to to go through a transition in
front of like the biggest audience in
the world
especially at a time now where
everyone's just like
making it their business your personal
life
so the last time Jimmy made this
he did one that was I cured uh blinded
and we all had a laugh at the thumbnail
was was was pretty funny I mean let's be
real it is funny
he's got he put tears on the kid and
you know the face he's making behind him
like yeah I did that [__]
so yeah I blinded this guy yeah
a thousand blind people see for the
first time
138 million views on that one by the way
so fast forward this one he dropped two
days ago 100 1 000 deaf people here
for the first time
and uh he did he did the same thing this
kid's like what
okay who are you and he's crying too
ugh
um
yeah Chris says only any pronoun so yeah
I don't think anyone needs to get
whatever it's his business okay anyway
but this one's not performing as well
I've noticed he's fudging with the the
thumbnails a lot
and when I watch this video and I'm a
fan you know I watch all of his videos
again
just gonna be real
uh here is all the thumbnails how did
you guys catch this
a lot of people did I was saying I
posted on online so this was the first
one I saw
and apparently this kid's Heath maybe
figured that this kid was just kind of
dumb and annoying looking so people
weren't clicking the video
Indian Child I'm not buying the tears
dummy
and so then he updated it to have like
uh radiation poisoning I think you have
a backwards I think that one's actually
the first one with the radiation and
then they removed okay because this is
the one I saw when I washed right
because this one at least makes sense
they got you know
they get this incredible Cutting Edge
hearing aid
that allows them to hear
but then they're like uh the hearing aid
is too like 5G
spooky I don't know so why the waves
coming out of the hearing wave or out of
the hearing aid should be coming in
huge discrepancy huge oversight on Mr
Beast part
you wouldn't be smiling so bright if you
had thought about that huh Jimmy yeah
and you know what like all the they're
putting all the blame out this kid what
about [__] Mr Beast changing up his
face every now and then like what the
[__] like [__] idiot bro blaming the
kid and [__] well Jimmy's like I make
this face in every video and they all
get tons of views so well it's getting
old Mr Beast oh she's depressed
Mr breast
got him dude you're [__] I'm done I'm
a fan I want to re-emphasize me too me
too me too we're just having a good time
here you know what I mean
so dumbass stupid kid but then we bring
in this kind of um
this kid who has he's much more
emotional the tears are just and from
both eyes my God streaming down and with
the ear he goes
more ethnically uh ambiguous as well
right I was yeah I didn't want to be the
one to say that thank you
and so this is nice uh
but in terms of thumbnail between the
three I would probably say that
I guess I don't think it really matters
frankly because I don't think the
thumbnail is the problem and I'm gonna
watch the video I'm going to tell you
guys that I here's my theory is that Mr
Beast is suffering from his own success
as DJ Khaled uh would say the king
so
um first some context
first some context
Mr Beast said on Twitter
almost 4 000 hours editing
has gone into my next video brand new
style wait what did you mean brand new
style
you're about to see
okay can't wait for you that is a little
confusing having watched It's the video
it's actually just like a weird like dub
it's like a distillation of
his already HD HD HD H ADHD ADHD editing
and then he just made it a d
because people can't say the whole thing
myself included
thank you sorry about that uh almost 4
000 hours of editing is gone in my next
video brand new style can't wait for
y'all to see it so when I actually saw
him tweet those I was like okay cool I'm
actually intrigued here it is it's six
minutes 14 seconds okay real quick He
also mentioned that uh that's gonna be
his best video ever it's going to change
YouTube he said that about this yeah
it's in that thread this is the direct
weight you know the thing is that
it's not that different than any of the
videos that was my impression kind of
the same part for the course it's going
to change YouTube best video ever
4 000 hours by the way that's 166 days
that's a lot of days
that's half a year
[Music]
round the clock
that's a whole goddamn like Barracks of
editors for six minutes 14 seconds so
anyway let's watch this and analyze it
and again I do this with peace and love
because I love Jimmy but this is
fascinating I mean uh you know as a
as a product of the internet I believe
it is our duty to understand what's
going on here
this is the first out of a thousand deaf
people that we're gonna help here again
and she hasn't heard her mother's voice
in four years
can you hear
don't let me
be huh next we help Kaylee why
and even entire families hear their
loved ones again but they are only a few
of them
so at this point I was like
okay this is a cool intro and then I
realized that's that's the video
they just told all these people's
stories
in half a second there's no more to it
and I do I feel that
he he's a slave to this ADHD editing I
want to know who these people are
it felt like I was watching a trailer
and I was like wait what the [__] first
out of a thousand deaf people that we're
gonna help here again and she hasn't
hurt her mother like I need a swoosh I'm
getting swooshes
it's only like six seconds long of
really compelling content and I need
swishes
this is the first out of a thousand
questions people that we're gonna help
here and she hasn't hurt her in four
years shock and then it's like I can't
just look at her face I need a [__]
like
uh
uh I need the green button to switch on
Cheers they're like oh oh and the color
came back oh that's awesome it's too
much Jimmy
chill the [__] out man
can you hear
it bye that's all you got
[Music]
Daddy they actually help Kaylee that's
that's all they get and then she gets
she gets green button bye green button
entire families hear their loved ones
again but they are only a few of the 1
000 I gotta leave man get give it a
little space we'll agree in the intro
maybe we'll get more details after the
that's what I thought but yeah
you know and I was invested in those
stories I wanted to know
I wanted to know more
people that we are gonna help here again
today also I got I got to be real that's
a little corny brother
the Beast symbol on the Earth
I was like come on dude I mean I think
it looks sick I mean it's it I I get it
but it's like come on bro you're not God
I'm gonna get my Beast heads in the chat
we still have their Mr Beast uh
uh emojis don't we also are you sure we
do let's go beast mode Let's Go Beast
Mode everyone that Mr Beast isn't God
well now that you mentioned that's I
mean that's a good counterpart right
that's all the evidence that's needed I
say we just remove Jesus's face with
that lion head tiger head
let's get Beast emojis in chat you guys
there we go here they come what the [__]
is this now this is getting clicks
right now there's a video essay Channel
with this exact thumbnail
how Mr Beast ruined his career in one
video
are you guys so tired of video essays
turned 1 000 kids gay guy today I'll be
turning 1 000 kids gay pandemic but uh
23 grandmother okay people together now
there's still there's still video essay
people that I like like D'Angelo Walsh
never misses but as a genre I'm so
[__] over video essays you guys
[Music]
anyone else
I mean I don't know if I'm ready to
right off the whole genre it's like
there's too many of them and they're
mass-produced and they're just dumb dude
and they're all like how this person
ended their career in one video how this
person's demise right well you're
talking specifically like it's all drama
commentary
video essay kind of thing yes okay
that's kind of the genre that I always
see but
I mean video essays people were making
like World thought out educational
content that's not a problem that's yeah
yeah here again today we
will okay so they spent three million
[__] dollars on Cutting Edge
technology sick and then like just go
back and like this is all you get this
is
this we're gonna help here again
[Music]
that's it
okay let's go back
three million dollars of Cutting Edge
hearing technology that unlike old
hearing aids analyzes people's specific
hearing needs and allowing them to hear
again without causing any damage can you
hear me talking now yes oh my God
he heard that that was that is a crazy
hearing aid
across town no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no [__] turn them off
Jay yeah or yeah Jay odd Audrey or
whatever is
jabry shot J Aubry makes good ones yeah
the Aiden Ross video is really I haven't
watched that it was good okay yeah
you're in it
yeah
w w
famous yes yes
and our tenth person was Aisha I used to
watch them like a lot like I used to no
stop
this is over
go ahead do a test mommy she can't hear
you yet but she will in three two
one hello
I can hear my baby girl oh is this
copyrighted music
a little bit
here play the play our music Zach our
royalty free stuff
people here again but on top of that we
wanted to give them a little surprise
this is ten thousand dollars okay now
this now this part I found funny because
it's like it's not enough now for Jimmy
to cure
their deafness
he spent three million dollars now he
also has to give them ten thousand
dollars because it's not enough
he's gone too far he can no longer top
himself
hmm you know what I mean like his his
content is just like bigger crazier more
money there's no you can't you know okay
you gave him ten thousand dollars you
know what I mean okay you cured his
blindness so what oh you made him here
again for the first time so what bro
let's have they has he visited the moon
no
boring
get to work get to work Jimmy
SpaceX
so that's I when he brought up the 10K I
was like oh come on and you know what I
mean
[Music]
it's like the
it sounds like you're saying that Mr
Beast jumped the shark
I'm not saying well no I'm not saying
that quite that hmm
because that would have said he can't
top himself anymore well Jumping the
Shark
implies that there's a specific moment
in which everything is worse after that
right which I don't think that's
happened okay but he has P I feel that
he's
he's cornered himself only ten thousand
beasts
come on bro 25 50 at least
five thousand longer
you go
we also want to give you ten thousand
dollars to make this day a little bit
better to make this day better I mean
you just cured her deafness
that wasn't enough
nobody's nobody agrees with me nobody
sees what I'm saying
I see what you're saying
thank you
[Music]
you can turn up his video now
hearing or the 10 grand very
here do you watch the channel can you
guys close your eyes and can I borrow
you for one second can you tell them you
guys just won ten thousand dollars okay
open your eyes you won ten thousand
dollars
this is like okay the blindness is or
the deafness is cool but now let's get
the reaction getting 10 000.
yes at ten thousand to all
seems like he gave ten thousand all of
them that's amazing of him like he's 10
million dollars he's so great
I can't believe he did all of that to
everyone there's no way but it yeah I
mean that would be just a couple that'd
be 10 million he would spend that much
money for six minute [__] ADHD crazy
ass video where you don't even get to
feel the impact of everything he's doing
I guess it's probably just a few people
look at the camera and you just go
subscribe subscribe there you go Ivy's
the next big YouTuber why don't we give
you ten thousand dollars as well here
you go see like these two there was more
time of them getting the ten thousand
dollars than there was of the mom
deafness being cured
isn't that weird
yeah
in terms of like setup of the video well
yeah I feel like we should be watching
them here here all of his videos just
people getting away but like in in a
sense like of
what people I guess find interesting
right the 10 000 is more interesting
than the deafness being cured
you know what I mean awesome not only
did we want to help you here we also
wanted to give you ten thousand dollars
on top of it like do you think it
overshadows it in the video it's just
the way it's like edited
yeah and there's like no setup to Big
Time yeah that's how I kind of feel like
I'm like so amazing of him to do all of
this obviously Ike actually care about
what he's doing yeah I want I want to
see it I want to see it but I don't know
why it's got to be like we did this
amazing thing all around the world I
spent three million dollars on and then
I gave each person ten thousand dollars
and that's the focus of the video I
don't get it
you know I'm not impressed I want a
cancer video
you want a cancer video Mr Beast heals
cancer okay now we're talking yeah
I honestly just want to see him crush a
Lamborghini I don't want him to do
you see him do something for himself I
want him to hire John Wick to try and
kill him
I know he's a net positive but I do
think this is an interesting social
commentary just like what the [__] is
actually this video is that uh Dan
thinks I'm kidding he actually has a
video I paid a real assassin to try to
kill me
he has a couple of those
what are you going to spend the money on
Yeah you mentioned you have 12 grandkids
no
um oh in here is twelve thousand dollars
no oh 12 000. so now you can give a
grand to each of your grandkids
you can just tell me what jokes are done
here you go is there something you want
to buy
well now you when we were talking
earlier they mentioned you guys enjoyed
jet ski is there anything you want but
you don't want to spend the money on jet
ski for him his jet ski broke down who
are you uh Mr Reese
wait did you just realize who I am yeah
oh that lady no oh okay yeah I'm the one
who helped you here well now that you
know who I am if I surprise you guys
with something yeah okay I went out and
I bought a brand new
okay this is continuing dude
you just cured the man's definite he
doesn't need a jet ski on top of it to
make it interesting
and of course he's more excited about
the Jets
the man can hear damn it that's good
it's just the uh
I don't know I'm the only one apparently
that finds this interesting
thank you
for you somebody said uh Mr Beast pays
for 1 000 uh gender affirming surgeries
there you go that'd be that'd be that'd
be a good [__] you though all the people
that would be crazy amazing holy [__]
this man's crying over the damn jet ski
you can hear bro you couldn't hear
before like I'm sorry but there's
something interesting here and I'm not
hating on Mr Beast I don't know how many
times I have to say that Ben's crying
over a [__] jet ski
he can hear
don't you understand what I'm saying
like there's some cure 1000 elderly
people's desire to jet ski
there's something wrong
for the commentary maybe on us maybe on
our society I don't know but there's
something wrong here
oh really I got you thank you so so much
I want to put those two on a jet ski by
the way
but didn't it say crash the old one or
something
is that what he said yeah he had one of
them I was about to get lost at sea dude
wait and then they had the yeah
I got you thank you so so much and while
we were busy helping more people I sent
Nolan to give a gift to one of our
youngest patients I've got some costume
pink hearing aids for you
listen what do you say we go get some
more toys they said no see this is
problem I love this
let's cure her I want
I want to and see her experience but now
it's not enough we have to go buy her
toys
what's the where's the video like I want
The Human Side I don't want like the
just the crazy consumption like life is
all about money and like and that has
more of an impact on the people too
because they don't they're curing their
[__] deafness isn't enough
they need toys like what the [__] and I
said no one to give him like what the
[__] I'm invested in this girl I want to
hear about it patience I've got some
custom pink hearings awesome look how
happy she is listen what do you say we
go get some more toys what are you
talking about
try it on let me hear what do we got to
go do it go to [__] Toys R Us now
dating yourself
Toys R Us is gone
well whatever you know I mean where do
you go buy toys I don't even know yeah
Amazon Amazon
oh Target's pretty fire I go yeah they
got great Legos well I mean look at her
response to toys that's what I'm seven
with little girl I'll give now here's an
interesting video you can choose hearing
or toys now we're [__] talk right
okay now we're cooking give me the
[__] Legos or hearing yeah yeah I
want to see that give me the toys give
me the pan or money
exactly we know where you stand on that
one
I chose Japan yeah I know I'm just
kidding you're a good man
did we ever decide what we're doing with
the vacation or is that still up in the
air nope we have not
let's do a Mr B Style video
uh okay
vacation or
lobotomy
we're just gonna go to the toilet hour
you just go crazy all right it's Jimmy's
money I'm taking all his money now I'm
going on this whole journey like she's
in this whole sixth minute 13 second
video she's getting a whole section
dedicated to her going and buying toys
do you see how [__] up this is
football odd yeah
look at this she's in Target buying toys
she just had her oh yeah
I want the hearing
not good enough it's not that's boring
that's why I find just so odd about this
whole damn thing toys colorful who wants
to [__] hear you know who needs a
hearing Keller be there no sight no
hearing she take the [__] toys you
don't need I'd rather live in a black
void of darkness and emptiness and
loneliness you don't need a hearing to
build that Lego set my friend that's
well
that's true I guess
oh what's that you like this man you
need more
focus is [__] insane
as much to this girl's shop get buying
toys dude you spent five million dollars
on this video
does she have her pink hearing aids in I
have no idea I was looking I didn't see
them man those were Beats by Dre
you probably picked those
they're cooler
[Music]
this doesn't work for me either I wanted
the pink I wanted the blue herring
AIDS not the pink ones [__] watch it
we're only at we're only at 83. out of a
thousand
and there's only like three minutes of
this video left to go well he's he's
yada yada's it's gonna have to do a lot
of yada yachting someone says it's not
for you these are for younger people no
it's not these are just for everybody in
the world they have like 200 million
views per video
it's not just for kids
stop it
also who cares am I not allowed to
analyze it
you have to pick me or Mr Beast right
now
I'll put up a poll
I'll lose come on I'll lose that one I
don't want it I don't wanna you have to
pick right now
Ethan listen I'm Pro Mr Beast
I'm I I keep Mr Beast
okay vote with your hearts everyone I
voted for Mr Beast
sorry
um
I'm gonna spend the next 50 hours buried
alive you know what you guys are so kind
I voted for Mr Beast but 82 said they
would choose for me to exist and I don't
know what the vote is are we talking
about like a Back to the Future fading
Polaroid type of thing or like one dies
one lives you you
you laid out the terms you said
everybody has to pick right now can I
tell us you something Zach I love that
sound bite
I love it every time you play it it's so
good whenever we have to do like
anything related I'm related well it
started from uh I think we were doing a
costume contest and abu's Marty McFly
okay
um
but yeah it just kind of It kind of grew
well with the show yeah it's so perfect
well about a fifth of our audience is
picking Mr Beast
no I'm I'm too bad but I'm I'm very uh
thrilled with the results of this poll
okay okay
I ain't fixing none of your hearing
though don't ask
I ain't got Mr Beast my I don't know can
you take me to Target Target's more in
my budget let's go
you know I'll drop 200 on toys for your
broke ass let's go
I'll buy you some Legos and [__] here we
go
yeah pretty cool isn't it yeah
you can hear I can hear really good I
hear myself pretty good
that's what I got myself I caught myself
that's the guy that got taken out by the
American flag parachute yeah I need the
hearing aids on
slammed my ears in the ground when a
parachute or hit come down and slam me
with one of them tactical mass shooting
intervention parachutist
Guster Friendly Fire by us more people
will be injured by the parachuters than
by the shooters
I'm running on that [__] it you're gonna
run for president on the on the
parachuting yeah American flag guys
thank you for the 10 uh 50 gifted for
members go up
who I'm assuming is our Saudi benefactor
it sure is and I apologize for the uh
for the IBS slander for earlier episode
we loved the we love slandering the
Emirates because they lost I don't think
I think you said Saudi Arabia forever
actually no I [__] on both of them okay
well I mean I called their King IBS well
he's just the prince he's just the
prince
don't tell him that he'll [__] saw
he'll saw your bones saw me yeah bonesaw
really good I hear myself pretty good I
tried talking to him from back there
Colton who's the best quarterback ever
Peyton Manning he hears very well to
test your new hearing we got you tickets
to the upcoming championship basketball
game it's the hearing is not the focal
point of these goddamn exchanges
okay to test your hearing we're going to
send you to a basketball game I'm not
like a concert or something be more
appropriate well there's super sports
fans right but you could enjoy a
basketball game without hearing
like it's not critical to the experience
it doesn't matter the [__] game I
want to know about the hearing the focus
isn't even on the hearing
it doesn't work either okay for you and
your whole family to go to there is
something to each gift being personal
yeah like that guy crashed his ski he
needed a new one yeah Mr B said okay
well some was just 10 grand right yeah
that's true but any any personal like
this man this little boy loves sports
I get that right and it's awesome and
it's nice but it's also perverse and
weird and [__] up that the curing the
the deafness is not enough and the focal
point is not the deafness there's a lot
of things that I love about Hitler I
didn't say that no but you were looking
like him just a second ago
I didn't say that I didn't say that
what better way to break in your new
hearing than going to Taylor Swift
concert okay that's fire like that's
amazing
personal Swifty's forever
peace forever
and today now that you can hear I'm
going to take your broke ass grocery
shopping
get some eggs some bread
they're broke dude get them from [__]
pasta marinara sauce
experience it with your new hearing
welcome to Houston
like the best seats you know it's like
there's a thousand people got their
deafness cured out oh I don't need to
see this kid at a [__] basketball
game
maybe I'm hating no
[Applause]
like you know okay why is this good so
much time
okay so now they go to Mexico
people
[Music]
wanted to hear their dog this one I
liked
what are unable to afford hearing
technology however today I love this one
it's been saying repeat
repeatedly which they're so excited to
hear us Say Mama and Papa for the first
time they're flicking them on okay three
two one
[Music]
this is very sweet I want more of this
now listen okay now let's go Diego buy
some toys
like all right now enough of that
[__]
T Swift tour
then I took her to the world's biggest
bouncy castle
for a pizza party
this I like you know what I mean for me
thank you you should be able to hear
them all right let's see how he out of
these idiots
[Music]
she hasn't heard
seven years three two one
yeah
how much different is it wow what's up
go ahead
that one tear it just seemed very fake I
don't know yeah
I would never accuse him of that the
teary wiped off his eyelid
I would never accuse me of that all
right let's go I got a yacht on the
coast let's go take a cruise
if you think this is cool wait to see my
yacht how much different is it I know
he's just doing a a nice thing but
this is what I'm saying someone said
even this is how you act every time you
order everyone food
okay that's not true come on
that's how I feel
right you are a saint for doing that you
wanna right thank you I know yeah
I know you're hungry at all I am hungry
actually now that they bring it up got
him what do you guys want
Mr Beast Burger you know what I want
a Jay Shetty Shake no oh
Boby yeah Bobby just think about it
I mean whatever you guys want you guys
want food you want Bobby I'm in for
whatever
I need food too I am hungry I want a jet
ski yeah that's what I want okay one jet
ski for cam
hey
all right let me finish this
[Music]
these are beautiful stories and he's
done this amazing thing I want to feel
it like this should be an hour long you
know what I mean I want to be there they
spend 4 000 hours editing this what why
how
and again
I guess it's a commentary on the
expectation on the con like this this is
really you could have like a whole
[__] documentary series about this
but it's been distilled into six minutes
half of which is toy shopping and
jet ski riding and [__] there's nothing
to do with the goddamn hearing yeah he
grounded us in one family for like less
than 30 seconds and those were the best
30 seconds of the video right exactly
Brazil Brazil and we also helped
hundreds of people in South Africa and
Indonesia this man has a global [__]
operation all we saw was some dumbass
kid at a Knicks game or whatever
that providing hearing isn't the only
way to connect people
it's also buying them toys
sorry sign language connects people
whether they can hear or not
Limited in many places so we're going to
donate a hundred thousand dollars to
organizations around the world that are
teaching people sign language but aside
from that we still have our final person
left to help one more oh this is gonna
be I think that this is that he saved
the best for Life there we go this is a
epic [__] moment I'm ready nine nine
out of a thousand let's make it happen
let's make it happen girl here we go
foreign
hype this one up and he's just like
peace out dead she's also died Lights
Out it's like lights out
your malfunctioned
snaps their brains
so okay so again
let's do a poll uh let's do it okay so
what's the pull
myself
your take question mark is the premise
Ethan's a demon
your take question what am I being
demonic am I being a douche Ethan is a
demon or
uh the the video was a little bit weird
a little bit weird or
demon you know what uh just say the
video was weird or the video was fine
the video was fine
the video was weird that's it
that's it bad pull
you made it so you're a weirdo bro I
didn't type it direct your complaints to
Ethan I'm fine
[Music]
love Howie
okay
weirdo bro
so in the the polls are moving a bit
around here
75 okay it's still moving around a
little bit all the Beast heads get in
there all the breast heads
let's go beast mode people
big massive dumps
so it seems like 30 or 27 Say the video
is fine
and again I'm not criticizing him
because this is incredible what he's
done
I'm criticizing like
people's appetite for Content I don't
know the the genre the ADHD editing is
like it's gone out of control
Elon Musk is uh defending Jimmy thank
you oh thank God and by the way I don't
think anyone's really this is just silly
[__] like right wing talking points
and I've seen this or not even right
when talking once he's just like
virtue signaling I don't know because he
goes amazing that Mr Beast can give a
thousand people their hearing back and
instead of asking why the heck the US
Health Care System didn't do this 15
years ago Americans are attacking Mr
Beast nobody's doing that they did the
same thing with the blindness nobody's
attacking Jimmy some people actually
were asking why is you know curable
blindness
not been fixed
by uh God that's Ed crassenstein
just realize who that tweet is by wait
who is he he's got a blue checkie that
means he's a Nazi
no he was like
I'm kidding it don't sue me loser idiot
no he's he's not right wing uh he he was
like super anti-trump in fact is he a
reply guy yeah he was like he was up
there with with the goat Jeff teedrich
Back in the Day always replying uh here
here's a classic
oh you already pulled it up our boy
Brian yeah sneak peek at the last page
of my upcoming book How The People
trumped Ronald plump
yeah he made a children's book about
Robert Mueller Brian not a real first of
all shame on you that was this guy that
that is that is like obscene dude why
did you make this dedicated the future
of America our children and the world's
children
why is he shirtless wearing like a
stripper color
would you like to buy a hardcover a
hardcover version of it for thirty
dollars for your for Bruce and uh no man
Theodore you want to read this no kids
no I hate it so much
yeah but okay so to me it's like some
virtue signaling thing where they're
like everyone's mad at Mr Beast nobody's
mad nobody's mad at Mr Beast this or the
last time everybody knows what he's
doing is good very good
right
[Music]
I'm just
feeling something okay I'm feeling
something and I'm trying to express it
yeah you're making a distinction between
like the charitable acts that he did
versus the the way that the content
chose to uh depict it well I mean he did
say it was a new style I don't really
disagree that it was a game changer or
the best video to ever be posted on
YouTube so he but that also confused me
because he said on Twitter this is
totally different new style 4 000 hours
editing and then it was to me
well whatever yeah listen I'm not trying
to criticize him I just found the whole
thing pretty wild here's an article deaf
people like me deserve better than Mr
BEAST's latest piece okay so inspiration
porn so I mean this guy's probably can
bite it but let's read it
when watching mysterious video will the
average viewer be more alert to the
needs of deaf people or will they
instead be drawn to the heroic
Donaldson oh that's his last name going
out of his way to Splash around cash in
a sense like that
[Music]
oh
very deserved I was about to hit it
myself
you gotta be faster bro I don't want to
be the always the only one hitting it
Philly D just put out a video talking
about this as well
all right well okay so I guess I'm gonna
have to defend Mr Beast then let me read
this when I had my first hearing aids
what did it cut did it catch that AB
when I had my first hearing aid switched
on it certainly wasn't a one and done
situation like Jimmy Mr Beast would have
us believe it's a sudden flooded noise
it was overwhelming and definitely
required more fine-tuning I've heard
that too that these really
high level
um
uh hearing aids
can sound really scary at first if they
haven't been fine-tuned hmm just like
too loud or no it's like robotic
sounding and crazy something okay
yeah this process isn't something that
fits neatly into a six minute video
which apparently took the online
personality team almost 4 000 hours to
edit
so instead we're left with viral content
which is nothing more than harmful
sensationalism I don't know that it's
harmful I mean that that seems to be a
reach don't you think
harmful what's his reasoning uh hold on
one sec
oh [__] I love the button you guys
you guys
the button
you know what [__] Charles let's
coordinate the button
button is King
why am I doing that I was meant to be
doing like this but smash that button
I'm not a little too stiff
do you need to hit the button again I
mean
but then it got yeah I mean I'm not
trying to do it I think it's fine yeah
okay dancing
[Music]
okay
oh dude you guys do the Boba orders
so last time I got the mango one but it
was too sweet
made me actually feel nauseous
milk
have you ever had a classic brown sugar
one is it super sweet
no I think it's more of the flavor Brown
it's like um
maybe like a normal Ass Coffee
with oat milk and Boba there was one I
thought that you would like earlier it's
frosty milk with espresso honey Boba and
coffee jelly oh my God good or bad does
it say the calories on it
um let me see that does sound very good
does not say the calories
I'll try that breaker okay you know boba
boba phenomenon is insane I mean either
were driving somewhere
oh yeah the Renaissance fair
it's in this really remote area you go
through the city
and it's pretty desolate
not a lot of people yet there's one boba
time that's [__] packed it's the only
store and it's packed
boba time dude
oh someone said Jasmine Jasmine Bubba
what's that Caitlyn Jones jasmine tea
maybe that could be nice that doesn't
sound like a lot of sugar
you can get less sugar in any any Boba
too like 25 or what's it 25 sugar
[Music]
get me the one you were planning on that
one's sweetened with honey so I
it's better than just sugar so
all right so that's it thank you
um after coming under Fire for a video
when she helped 1 000 people uh cure
blindness he decided to double down on
video is it again I don't like the
framing it's not like
he's doubling down you know he likes
helping people
which is good
going as a way to help people from the
disabled Community the time
uploading a video titled 1 000 deaf
people here for the first one the video
thumbnail alone hints at what the angle
is going for
a young boy cups a right hand over his
ear with tears photoshopped on his
cheeks I mean that is a little corny I I
will side with you on that one
you know
it's exactly like the clips you see
online of babies crying when they have
their hearing aids switched on but again
that doesn't tell those story but Mr
Beast has produced here is flat out
inspiration porn a term coined by the
late great activist Stella young back in
2014 to describe the objectifying of
disabled people for the benefit of
non-disabled people
okay
this is worth reading just because this
dude is actually deaf so I want I want
to know what his criticism is
with the flick of a switch Mr Beach Mr
Beast actually has each switch on be
accompanied with a misleading toggle
animation individuals from multiple
different countries can suddenly hear
and so ends their moment in the video so
we just move on to the next person Mr
Beast can help like some auditory Jesus
this is just one part of the problem and
that it amplifies the dangerous
misconception that hearing devices such
as hearing aids and uh cochlear Cochlear
implants are cures or fixes for deafness
they aren't
they simply produce the sensation of
hearing
they do not restore it but they did hear
I mean like they would say something and
they heard what they said I mean I don't
know how this stuff works though they do
not restore it and when deaf people take
off these advice for whatever reason say
to go to sleep they are in these moments
deaf yeah it's a hearing aid obviously
there's nothing in mysterious video
which acknowledges the fluctuating
relationship we deaf people have with
hearing and listening it's not a binary
process that we suddenly go from deaf to
hearing but rather these devices are as
the name suggests they're to Aid hearing
and help us pick up on auditory
information we might not catch otherwise
not only that but the video fails to
properly emphasize the element of choice
deaf people have around whether they
want to use them or not yes these
devices are expensive but some will try
hearing aids or receive a Cochlear
cochlear I don't know
Cochlear implants cochlear I know what
that is where they the brain implant
that
that helps you listen here only to find
that they aren't the right fit for them
others will decide not to explore them
entirely
and individuals won't be eligible for
them all together at which point they
might use sign language to communicate
instead of speech with the help of
hearing I mean he did touch on the sign
language and did a donation
foreign
you better call him Mr B so I'm getting
tired of the disrespect
McDonald's would only consider sign
language as something to tack on at the
end of his video though saying providing
hearing isn't the only way to connect
people and the sign language does so too
but struggling to underline the fact
that deaf people can choose how they
want to connect with the world
didn't just tack it on it was a big part
of the video it was like I mean probably
about 20 seeing as simple as yeah this
article is very silly yeah I'm
it's he's not he he's really trying to
paint it where like he's a he's
explore I don't know a bad guy but it's
just not the case
now in my opinion what I'm picking up on
is a better measured kind of
documentarian Style video would have
been
way better
and he could have touched these Nuance
issues too you know
uh uh I mean we only need to look at Mr
B's asking one individual if they think
hearing or the 10 grand is better news
that's what I want
to know that the philanthropist is still
shockingly out of touch when it comes to
a disability
wait he did he he didn't ask someone
that yeah that was that was one part of
it hearing or the 10 grand yeah he made
them choose no he just asked them what
was better after he gave them 10 grand
did they did he show their answer yeah
and they said hearing
oh right
he would have cut it if they didn't
knew Arden fan he asked he asked 999 of
them they all said the money
new art and fans of Donald Donaldson
might well dismiss all this legitimate
criticism well you say it's legitimate I
mean sheer criticism as me simply being
a hater you're a hater
despite my lived experience he's doing a
good thing they may say why can't you
just appreciate that he's trying to help
people I don't dispute that Mr Beast may
have good intentions and that a rich man
doing something charitable will warm
many anti-capitalist heart
but benevolent ableism very much exists
I don't I don't think he I don't think
that's fair ableist
disabled
man
you don't have to be
unashamedly abusive and discriminatory
to be an ableist sometimes even the most
casual and well-meaning actions can be
harmful to deaf and disabled people
I'm talking about the hearing content on
Instagram blah blah blah
but here's the thing he says in closing
deaf people like me need hearing people
to speak up along us not just for us
okay dude I don't know what to say about
that I mean
I think the article alone is okay like
he brings up a lot of good points but I
don't know if it's Mr BEAST's
I don't know it just feels like it's
critiquing too much almost yeah he's
coming down way too hard on Beast yeah
but the article in general is like fine
we're just connecting it to the Mr B's
video doesn't really make sense
right I think that right the issues are
interesting
yeah
but I don't know I'd call him ableist
you know
it's not like he's laughing at people in
scooters falling backwards and slamming
their head on the ground
yet the few experiences that were shown
where we watched someone here for the
first time it looked like they were very
grateful and it looked like everything
was good and they were helped in that
yeah yeah totally
Philly D uh made a video about it should
we watch that or whatever could probably
move on
but um
you know I just find it all interesting
oh yeah so Mr uh Elon Musk came to his
defense he said
people definitely shouldn't be attacked
for doing good
yeah for example I get I offer to give a
girl a horse what's wrong with that
trying to do something nice for her and
I got all this [__]
is it really just a question of money to
restore hearing I'm always looking for
ways to donate money that are actually
good perhaps this is one
it is very hard to donate money if you
if you about it doing actual good not
merely the appearance of okay show me
the receipt
I'll show you the richest man in the
world you can't find a worthy [__]
place to donate dummy Elon Musk needs a
Mr Beast to tell him where to donate his
money
I hate him you know what sucks
oh God this interview with Bill Maher
did you see this
Bill Moore Alba gave him a hand job yeah
I I was gonna say the same thing it was
a total jerk off session he is such a
hack Bill Maher yeah I used to be a fan
of his
I think Trump broke his brain I actually
do think that or
it's it's all the same thing though they
can't get over the gender and the
pronouns and then they get they can't
face it the same thing happened to
Chappelle like they can't move past it
and then they get sucked into a
right-wing Vortex which is the only
people that agree with them
new rule I get to give Elon a hand job
new rule new rule I get the swallow
new rule folks he kept saying that he
was like
the biggest person to change the world
um it was again total jerk off session
well
whatever new rule
what's the new rule
I get all of Elon musk's semen new rule
Elon Musk must come in a Ziploc bag and
deliver it to me
take that liberals
so there it is I have some thoughts you
know and that that's what they are
does here on this podcast we have
nuanced we have uh we have open and
honest discussions and here's Helen
Keller on a jet ski thanks to Mr Beast I
like that
she can't see her here but damn she can
feel the breeze let the conversation
begin
she can feel she can feel the Mist the
breeze right before she slams into the
dock and I feel this
dumb she's such a she's such a fraud
you know what I mean oh you can't hear
or see stop it
how do I know she can even think she's
like a black box
how do I know it's not an Android
if you'd say I'm good on healing my
hearing but could I maybe get another
10K right did you see it Black Box she
is either no information or out
how do you know what goes on in the Box
you can't
you can't exactly
now rest in peace to the goat
barrier with a jet ski we need to we
need to exhume Helen Keller and put a
jet ski in her grave jet skiing and
Eugenics those are her two favorites
that's it and parachuting with American
flags
needs to rest peacefully
I'm going to take her skeleton and
fasten it like it's riding the jet ski
and then just plop it back down
all right let's talk about King's
sausage fingers shall we
he's a good man
King Charles III
74 years old this man is old as [__]
that God damn Lizzy in a box she just
wouldn't die
okay
and I'm just saying this this boy ain't
gonna have much time on the throne with
the size of those fingers
King Charles III Britain's new monarchy
in a monarch in seven years was crowned
King
at west miss minster Abbey on Saturday
the Archbishop of Canterbury place the
ancient crown of Saint Edwards on his
head during the ceremony
you'll need to chill with all that
some goofy [__] I'm sorry King look at
this
whatever King
somebody had the best uh reference they
said they can't help but think of like
Dark Souls 3's weapons when they see all
these guys and I asked what's uh what's
the stats on that Crown you think
probably killer I mean that's a rare
Relic do you think that gives like Stam
Regen
definitely yeah or definitely some kind
of intelligence and love oh you think
it's an infield it might be cursed
though actually it's a Faith Build it's
probably a Faith Build I think it gives
health
did Elizabeth
did she wear that crown or is that a
different Crown that's the crown no I
think they all rock with the same Crown
oh no that's that's that's the crown so
yeah she definitely had above normal
Health stats it's true but she had a
hell of Vitality yeah
right Queen Elizabeth maybe a res maybe
maybe like a res with full health oh
that's true
got like a re-res mechanic this man's
dual wielding scepters bro that's pretty
fire dude
miracles
no those are melee weapons bro oh you
think so yeah he just goes to town with
them
decks it's a DEX Build decks dual wheel
build with the cape and [__] it's fire
also it's a pretty light outfit so his
Dodge rolls is really good
this is so silly I don't think he's a
player actually I think that's a boss
that's that's King Charles the decrepit
rises again how many health bars do you
think he has how many phases oh he's
fast but yeah so when he when he drops
the first time yeah he's resurrected as
a the spirit of of uh Master Hand what's
the word the spirit of ravaged
civilizations of the British Empire oh
it's like kind of like they come out of
the crown gems wow it's just like all of
the Dead uh people from India and the
spirit Africa yeah that's like the uh
void Beast right
bro look at him he looks confused as
hell he's what the [__] is this [__]
he's so annoyed dude it's like can't get
this over with shit's heavy I'm actually
probably is pretty heavy that Crown
heavy lies the crown I gotta be honest
I'm quite amused by all this how heavy
is the British crown
it's 10 pounds
uh it's five actually I just looked it
up whoa you just got uh
[__] citizen are you
poser
hold on I saw one giant scepter that was
uh like literally a Dark Souls weapon
coronation giant uh mace
Dark Souls dude you got to see this
um Arch so much oh here it is here it is
[__] bro you guys look at this
[__] dude
that's a [__] Dark Souls weapon
it is
how [__] sick is that
oh my god oh now that's a that's a
strength weapon right there that thing's
like solid gold too you know they like
slayed like a million African villagers
yeah like all their gold just to make
that one scepter well also the uh
Carriage that was being pulled was was
the same gold like it was insane like it
was like a three million dollar Carriage
it was insane I am I don't believe they
still do all this ridiculous stuff it's
so silly it's the silliest [__] I've
ever seen in my life yeah what they take
it so seriously and it's all make
believe play pretend dress up they just
keep coming back alive
they're being great in the actual world
yeah here's his Royal Fingers
um I guess getting ready to Crest the
ring as you can see this one struggled
this ring how'd they get that on I think
they have you been wearing that for like
yeah 30 years it's not how did they get
it on it's
how they get it off bunker well yeah I
mean obviously it's not coming off but I
I that's why I was wondering how long
he's been wearing it because I didn't we
go that didn't slip on you know I wonder
if we could do some Recon and find the
earliest picture of him wearing this
ring
um
I mean he must have a heart condition
with all that swelling let's ask Chad
gbt what is it what is super puffy hands
mean
well ankle I know ankles means some type
of vascular
the real reason King Charles always
wears a ring on his pinky
I mean I already know the real reason he
can't get it off no no it doesn't fit on
the other fingers it was made for his
ring figure it doesn't fit on anything
else it's a royal fashion this is
not a wedding these articles it's not a
wedding ring although he also wears that
piece of jewelry I don't care I know
it's not a wedding ring
this large gold band is called a Signet
ring oh the gentleman's ring is often
worn on the pinky of one's non-dominant
hand
uh-huh
okay
he's been wearing his photograph wearing
the ring since the mid 1970s oh yeah
that's 50 [__] years that thing's
been juicing on his pinky damn watching
a wiener I wonder I heard Mr Beast was
actually at the coronation
mm-hmm
what's his role
uh he was uh
he was handing out toys to make it more
exciting I don't know
sorry
he looked this is just he doesn't yeah I
mean
looks like a dumb ass dude thank you yes
idiot
we love the crown though let's see uh
temporary fluid retention a sudden
change in
no but okay it says temporary fluid
retention a sudden change in temperature
high blood pressure and arthritis could
all explain his puffer hands puff your
hands
but it's a chronic illness he always has
fatties it is known what caused it is
not known what causes Charles sausage
fingers
but the symptom is also linked to
secondary disease
of
dactylitis what is that dactylitis
pterodactylitis I was going to say it
sounds like a dinosaur disease
I got mad dactylitis dead dinosaurs
dactylitis is the medical term for
severe swelling that affects your
fingers or toes okay well there you go
sounds like he's got that it's the
hundreds and hundreds of years of
inbreeding that's frankly that's the
real answer yeah
oh we have a whole album of his fingers
okay this is your argument here let's
take a look
so this Ring's been on for 50 years it's
awesome
uh here's our boy look at those juicy
saucers man I'd fry those up for
breakfast why apparently he's now
insecure about them so there's photos of
him putting his hands behind his back
did you try draining them
did you try score uh pop possum in the
juicer
those suits are AI generated dude
this photo does look AI generated
[Music]
our boy dude he does he does an outfit
change in every
um photo it's kind of fire big fan of
the Lakers by the way okay no way bro
no [__] way that's not real is it
what do you mean no it is
all right Shelby old boys
from the phone
that looks like a
[Music]
this is photoshopped right
no
you think that his hand looks
unrealistic there oh stop are you
[__] with me is this photoshopped
look at the size of those Piggies
hypertension dude no way man
his index features got more girth than I
got
bun with some mustard called a day
Charles please as well
damn I gotta get me some hypertension
bro [__] look at this [__] A plump on
that man
some relish mustard
you know for a fact he's one good boner
away from a heart attack
[Music]
yeah I think his fingers just get harder
we love King Charles we kid the ones we
love and the royalty is
you know God save them
God save them man God Save the King
[Music]
here is the king
uh waving hello
here is Katy Perry why is Katy Perry
here that's the concert they had after
us the first time they did a concert the
[__] yeah it was huge I don't know why
she was selected in particular it's not
like there's a lack of British pop stars
Prince Charles is a firework that's why
he loves that song
babe
I mean I can't really think of any good
music that came from England yeah we
have to get Katy Perry
way better than the Beatles yeah it is
kind of wild right like a concert I
don't know this thing's kind of corny
like [__] Lionel Richie too that's
kind of hype I'm not gonna lie Lionel
Richie yeah it's just like his favorite
artist that's awesome actually they took
his Spotify rap and got everyone on
there I think I think the king is a very
big fan of American Idol because there
are two judges on that yeah maybe
very odd
Let's see we got all these kind of
I don't understand the concert thing I
guess back in the day they just used to
have like a Like Gladiator Arenas and
sacrificed a bunch of peasants to lions
that's more hype
probably more like a like a tournament
or something like that tournament yeah
maybe not human sacrifice I don't think
they ever
well not directly not directly anyways
yeah
there it is congratulations to King
sausage fingers the third
who is now the king I don't know if the
chest is trolling but I'm seeing a lot
of people say
they all said no
they said no to what to perform it
that's why they had to get Katy Perry no
shot who would say no to that
I mean
to be fair there's lots of British
people that aren't really down like
there's lots of anti-royalists in
Britain oh this person um alarm says his
fingers is from alcoholism he drinks gin
all day
badass
okay King
here's Katy Perry looking for a seat at
the coronation okay
bro you got it you can't see through the
damn hat
he's walking around with like a thing
just covering her whole face
she's like
why don't you take a seat right over
there there is Katy Perry
like a firework
and uh walking through the wind like a
plastic bag
now um
Olivia found this article
that of all the people that said no
there's a lot actually wait for real
Elton John was asked said no Helen John
said no to the Crown The Spice Girl well
the Spice Girls said no so they did
invite all the good Adele Harry Styles
wait what Robin Williams Robbie Williams
okay I understand why he said no oh yeah
I'll say they really have the [__]
Resurrection Stone over there right
wait why did they all pass just because
it's controversial uh some of them were
like schedule conflicts I'm reading
dude the crown doesn't have sh that's it
they have no clout you've got no wow
you can get the Spice Girls to perform
for the king would you want to perform
for the king
I wouldn't I would want to perform for
the king
[Music]
wait I can't hear oh Jesus what happened
I'm trying to fix it
so they could see me yeah they can see
you can't hear you
so I'll say man
sorry guys we said a little Tech issue
we know what happened
someone said we're back here people are
saying we're back audio back
audio's back yeah but oh this is so
fuzzy
uh I can hear again I don't know
oh it's fine
okay great
oh the buttons out oh no but we already
got our mileage
we got our one saved for the episode
smash that button
all right we're flying without the
button folks I'm so sick of this pucker
your buttholes
I was saying uh congratulations to love
we have 800 000 followers on tick tock
the funny thing is since our account got
restored from its permanent ban it does
it no longer says H3 podcast it just
says
user49875-997-676 yes sir which is
you can't yeah we can't change it
so if you go to the comments and if it
shows up on your feed it just says user
49785 yeah and so now all the comments
are like
user49875-997676 is my favorite podcast
it's increased our engagement so much so
I think I might keep it it's increased
how do you figure well like there's like
a billion comments about it on every
video like who the [__] is this
and I will say that since we came back
uh from the band we've been juicing
let's go Tick Tock is doing good yeah
we're back baby oh yeah 800 TPI thank
you
all right so let's let's do the
PowerPoint what do you say
I'm living for it
yeah I'm gonna go to the bathroom
and then when I come back we'll do the
uh all right all right I've got a lot of
super chats to get caught up on actually
[Music]
taking off the real quick uh the the
drama or the drama PowerPoint we did
last week got like went viral on Tick
Tock
my friends from school were sending it
to me they were like my friend sent me
this showed me that you're going viral
yeah like almost hit 4.7 million views
you did such a good job editing it like
all the PowerPoint in the video
thank you thank you you did all the hard
work
beautiful Teamwork Makes the Dream Work
baby yeah teamwork yeah all right before
we start this Taylor Swift stuff I need
to talk to my swifties
um this news just broke I put together a
quick little thing so I'm not going to
be going into all of the horrendous
stuff that you guys
um are talking about with Maddie her
potential new boyfriend
um so I'm not talking about all of his
controversies just talking about what
has happened over the weekend nice thank
you also on that note to all my Zach
Lewis fans out there it's your last
chance to buy tickets there's 50 left
actually a little bit less now thank you
yeah I'll be there Saturday yes it is
coming up I'm so excited
we're rehearsing we're playing we got a
great set list
um new songs old songs cover songs
any song we'll all be there yeah it's
gonna be a fun time
y'all done
sure yeah okay
uh Happy Birthday to somebody's uh
bestie page they turn 22 today we'd love
to see you guys so much it would be an
amazing birthday gift well happy
birthday to your bestie page and thank
you for the donation uh today is my 27th
birthday I'm a pediatric or nurse and I
always watch your shows after work to
decompress
thanks for everything you're welcome
thanks for being here and happy birthday
uh it's my 21st birthday 21. there's so
many birthdays today it's my 21st
birthday I just got myself a membership
as a gift to myself that is that is the
best gift that you can buy for yourself
there's a membership to the History
Podcast uh another
another 21st birthday 21. [__] you
shout out to the family in Ila peace and
love peace and love
can be honest
I think some of you are lying
turning 21. I think they're talking like
every episode there's like 10 people
turning 21 in this audience
they want to hear that [__] sound but
I think it's cat
uh
let's see chat don't be sexist and make
up rumors about Taylor Swift challenge
impossible
um that must have been earlier that was
at the beginning of the episode were we
even talking about Taylor Swift
I don't know what what that's about
uh
uh loving the boss mom buys from Ila
let's see I'm looking for something
um
some juicer once
uh
my sister's been admitted in a hospital
for mental health oh I'm sorry to hear
that uh and we're not sure when she's
getting out mental health should be
respected and taken seriously
uh I agree with you on the taken
seriously I don't I don't I don't
respect it necessarily
why
just I mean
it's a it's a terrible thing that a lot
of people struggle with i i it's kind of
like I see it as like a negative do you
disrespect it
oh you're talking about the like mental
health just in general do you hate the
mentally ill no that's not what I'm
saying but I heard I don't know if I
have respect for it necessarily
because it's your enemy
right right but not like the people we
love the people the people isn't the
problem the player hate the game right
exactly yeah exactly
um
thanks Mr Beast for making 40K people
here here again here here again does
that mean
oh one more yeah back
one more uh before we go a 21st birthday
there's like three 21st birthdays today
do you think these people are lying 21.
that's a good question there's a lot of
them asking while you were gone but you
know what whatever I don't care if they
want it they get it 21. holy [__] this
is what it looked like it was cutting in
and out like this that's crazy what the
f that's the Matrix old sausage finger
sends his regards yeah um
we'll have to talk after the show but
our our streaming computer is I think
dying okay
we can do what you got to do something
about that
yeah so let's do the um
let's do the uh the T okay let's do the
T
um
go ahead just take uh here let's do it
like we usually do I'll open the
PowerPoint
and then
uh you just tell me when beautiful now
I'll say this you know I
I'm not very familiar with Taylor Swift
lore I do know that I like her yeah me
too based on videos I've seen stuff
she's said I think she's cool I like her
all right we love the tea swizzies so
what is the premise here today so the
premise here today is that um Taylor
Swift and her boyfriend of six years
recently broke up and now there's a lot
of speculation because she's on tour so
she's
widely seen every day people are
speculating that she has a new boo okay
how long has it been it's been a weekend
I'm gonna take you through it okay okay
good yeah I always it's been a whirlwind
of a weekend for Twitter okay wow yeah
so so
Taylor Swift and her Boos are players
Taylor Swift
so this is her ex yes Joe Alwyn they
dated for six years so who is he other
than handsome he's an actor Ian was
saying that he hasn't really seen him in
anything
I had never seen him in
any but um
yeah he hasn't really been
broke he's in
he's an actor you got you gotta be like
to date Taylor Swift you have to be very
soon yeah you got to be you can't you
got to be working
[Music]
you can't be threatened by her success
because she has so much of it no no not
to say that he was oh he was you think
man he doesn't have a job
well okay so
Maddie Healy he is the lead singer of
The 1975 a little bit controversial bad
boyish looking bad boyish yes
[Music]
um they were rumored to be to have been
dating about 10 years ago they
definitely at least hung out and there
are a few songs that are like speculated
to be about each other but it's been a
decade now what's what's controversial
about Maddie
uh Matt Brittany Broski talked about it
a little bit when she was here
um just like there are things that he
has done that I I'll get butchered if I
get anything wrong so
okay so he's uh okay okay yeah
insensitive comments and I think more
yeah stuff okay so Splitsville
Joe and Taylor
broke up and it was announced by
Entertainment Tonight on April 8th and
the world lost their minds let me ask
you this yeah how does Entertainment
Tonight find out they broke up do they
give a press release I think what
happens is that
um when a celebrity wants news to break
they will have one of their like intels
who's in touch with each media Outlet
they'll like reach out to their specific
rep at the news outlet and they'll say
hi I have a tip Joe and Taylor broke up
and then it'll be reported that's wild
they gotta seed their own yeah it's like
a relationship status okay so they broke
up we thought that they were going to be
together forever even though he was
broke and jobless yeah maybe
okay
um this is one of my favorite favorite
comments ever this was underneath
entertainment tonight's uh announcement
it says
delete it please there's a lot of people
asking to delete it please several
people asking please delete it we beg
you there are people feeling sick people
are seeing this there are people crying
deleted deleted please people are
feeling sick this is everybody's asking
you to delete and it has over 3 000
likes because it's just too like
traumatic it's too triggering I think
because she's released so much art that
is seemingly dedicated to him people
feel connected to their relationship
it's traumatic this breakup they are
breaking up with him they are breaking
everybody else is breaking up we feel
yeah we're sharing her pain of course
absolutely
next
so this is a serious comment yeah
and how old do you think this person is
I imagine there was a bit of irony
written into it but they meant to it's
hard to tell I think young adult I don't
think like 12. no no I think like near
my age okay wow
um Taylor and Joe have broken up ET
reports what the [__] does he know okay
that was good those are good I like
those memes okay so this is the first
time Joe has is seen since news of their
breakup if you I zoomed in on the next
slide if you want to take a peek he does
not you were like oh no he doesn't look
good wow yeah you think she dumped his
ass
looks like there's a lot of speculation
about it some people some like news
outlets said an Insider told them he was
actually threatened by her success so
yeah another one some people are
speculating that she cheated on him but
then all of her friends unfollowed him
which they didn't unfollow all her like
Calvin Harris is her another one of her
ex-boyfriends someone like Gigi Hadid
whose best friends with Taylor Swift
still follows Calvin Harris but Blake
Lively Gigi and Ryan Reynolds all went
out to dinner with Taylor Swift and
right afterwards they all unfollowed Joe
so people are like I wonder what that
means wait they actually tracked the
timeline of that yeah yeah dude people
are so wild they went ate dinner
and then people notice the time yeah one
though it was a lot of it was like the
Heim sisters too they all unfollowed him
so people were like I wonder if he did
something bad but he must have but I
don't know he must have I want to know
that's all that's all I have to say is I
want to know
okay next so Taylor is on her era's tour
right now it's her her tour it's an
accumulation of all of her eras all her
albums it's a huge deal tickets were a
mess to get let's go she's under intense
uh public
scrutiny scrutiny yeah okay okay
suddenly the Sun out of nowhere on May
3rd reports that Taylor has a new
boyfriend Maddie Healy of the 1975. so
the world is like
hold on I thought that we were grieving
we were grieving this relationship we
were all obsessed with for six years
and what was the time difference here I
see you have the date so this is April
20th yeah he was seen for the first time
April 20th they announced April 8th
April 8th tonight and then we're looking
at however almost a month later yeah we
do have to keep in mind that they could
have broken up way before that
hmm
we would have known you think you think
our inside or whatever tonight
I think he's right I mean what the
closeness people follow right
I knew it
hmm
is this by Taylor Swift something was up
did we stand him is he is he good enough
for her we don't know yet the new dude
yeah I will say 1975's music I do like
okay I need to do some digging I wasn't
sure if I knew any of their music uh
when we were talking about for the show
like I've heard of that band a bunch of
times
um there's one song that you definitely
have heard
um all the rest of it I was like I have
no idea what this is you like it
the one song is like kind of okay but
um
but the other ones I listened to was not
vibing with Matt Healy age he looks kind
of young oh he's 34. okay yeah they're a
perfect age for each other
but this is not marriage material I can
tell girl like you need a real man you
think no marriage material no he's a bad
boy rocker he's not gonna be good for
her yeah he's oily definitely husbands
so he's not going to be loyal he's gonna
respect her interesting no I wonder he's
very like sappy though
he's sappy yeah
kind of beta-ish
sigma-ish Sigma built his own path like
rudy-ish as long as he's not beta as
long as he's not Beta Sigma is good
actually yeah really good we could hit
Sigma Sigma is really good so the next
day hey wait okay there you go people
are freaking out they're like where what
what is the base for this like 1975 they
were in the Philippines performing
Taylor was in Nashville performing like
why do why are they saying this all of a
sudden we have no we have no proof
however
May 4th the day after Maddie says in the
Philippines into the camera this song is
about you you know that and I love you
the next day hold on yeah yeah
what what am I watching here so here
after Maddie mailed that into the camera
he was at era's tour he went from
Philippines to Nashville he would sit in
the audience at Taylor's show and she
looked into the camera on stage and goes
this one's about you you know you and I
love you he said it on stage the night
before and people are saying that they
both said it on stage they did both say
it on stage you can look
this is about you you know that I love
you
oh well did she say it into a mic or no
it's like she's talking to him
no no you just have to watch you just
have to watch Wait so the audience
didn't hear it you just had to read her
list you can read her lips yeah Jesus
that's pretty subtle stuff guys well I
mean people are pretty smart
um
okay let me see let me see it so she's
apparently saying
this one's for you this one's about you
you know that though and I love you oh
thank you so much
better okay you know what
we're gonna have to hold the phone
because it is boba time baby
[Applause]
sure yeah all right this one looks
pretty awesome I was skipping today but
[__] it you got it it was all foamy at
the top
[Music]
um
that is very sweet but it's very good
and they put some semen on top man oh my
god
oh there's like
duh
there's like a square boba in here it's
the coffee jelly okay wait so do you yes
or no yes or no do we like it or no I
don't like the jelly okay also the drink
is good it's too sweet though really
it's really
sweetness taste it honey in it face it
it's crazy hmm
well now it's yummy though it is good oh
I love
[Music]
them but
it tastes like beef jerky on my diet if
I drink like eat too much sugar at once
I think I go into like a diabetic coma
no it's not right
I'm not seeing her lipping I'm not
seeing her lipping it you'll see just
watch it this one's about you she said
I've watched it like 10 times okay watch
him first then okay watch it slower but
with Boba this is about you you know
oh so he didn't also say it he did this
first
so neither of them set it into the mic
no which is why everyone's like obvious
he's saying it to the camera
[Music]
you know what I'm saying
and he was in the audience the night
that she did it
okay if they're actually there
oh they're there he was there the night
that she did it he was in the
Philippines not with her the night
before when he did it so people are like
oh that's their message to each other
he's drinking on stage it was also
before he sang She's American which
people speculate is about her I don't
like that he's drinking on stage he
always he needs to grow up if he's going
to be a good man to her no you know he
also eats like raw steak on stage Maybe
only babies eat raw steak Taylor you can
this is about you
oh people are saying she
she's saying you know who you are not
you know this is about you so let's see
that so let's go back to Taylor's
this one's about you
think you know that and I love sponge
about you
I think you know you know that and you
say that they're like and I love I love
you
I'm sorry this is kind of ridiculous not
really the same exact thing I don't
really think it's ridiculous so wait
he's not in the audience though and this
one yes he is
but and then she wasn't in this he
wasn't in his audience he did at first
the night before he was in the audience
the next night when she did it
do we see you really think they're
coordinating this like yeah
Taylor Swift is the queen of Easter eggs
first of all and second of all I feel
like before they sing songs about the
person they're dating if it's like this
one's about you and it's like oh he said
something so cute about me last night on
stage I'm gonna say the same thing what
if it's about her ex
you think
she's like was it a new song
how recently did the song get written I
just dedicated is she re-gifting a song
right now she's it's a dedication is
this a really good I I don't know what
song she was about to well hold on guys
before you say that we're reaching this
tweet says starting to feel like I'm a
documentarian what are you planning
Taylor Swift to Matty Healy this is not
my favorite 50 000 likes yeah because
they said seven million views
wow so there has to be something to it
right
is not I mean the fact that he was there
in the audience gives him a lot more
yeah and there's more we've got more
yeah I'm gonna need a little more though
before I got a lot okay you know I'm not
doubting what they said I believe you're
100 on that but why are they doing it
you think do you think they I think
they're they're crazy a little bit
they're flirting yeah so they're not
doing this to like kind of just stir the
tea I think both with the funds okay
yeah yeah makes sense Taylor loves to do
that and I love that she does that okay
yeah okay so then the next night he
performs on stage with Phoebe Bridgers
who's Taylor's opener and then he was
seen dancing in the audience with her
while Taylor was on stage that's cool
he's there next so Phoebe is her opener
yeah
and he's dancing with her yeah they've
been rumored to be dating before but
people are always messy what kind of
dancing are we talking about do we have
videos no just like dancing along to
Taylor Swift singing they weren't like
not like with each other got it got it
right just vibing okay yeah okay okay
this is my favorite part yeah
this
is May 7th so the night that he was
brought on stage he went out into the
audience and hung out with that's Gigi
Hadid one of Taylor's best friends so he
was in like the Taylor Swift friend box
and he was videotaped and photographed
during Taylor Swift singing her song
Lover pretty much melting and then Gigi
like put her hands on his uh on his
shoulders like yeah that's a done deal I
feel like that is like that's cute
like that's her being like ah you are
dating my friend why did she turn around
so fast though the turnaround on her
last boyfriend was really fast on a
six-year relationship people are talk
people are talking about it they say
like one month for every year to get
over
you think she should wait six years no
one month six months I was like six
years wait how long was it after they
broke up
well it was announced by Entertainment
Tonight on April 8th a month less than a
month really scandalous but also like I
know Jordan we're already at the I love
you stage okay what about you if if you
were with someone for six years let's
imagine they were having problems for
like
I mean if it's a six-year relationship
maybe like at least a year I don't know
maybe it's it's by the time you've
broken up you're like I'm ready and
months that's a little ear portion okay
Jordan Peters you're ready to maybe go
find a rebound but uh like I love you
right this huge public displays it is a
little while I know that Taylor has a
has a history of fraught relationships
that she writes music about right she
has what she has like contentious
fraught relationship breakups
um she's always writing music about her
axes I know that is that right yeah
people do say that a lot and like yes
she does allude to X's but like when you
really think about it so does
most musical artists talk about their
life you know
that's fair
like yeah she's writing songs about
being in love because she was she was in
love you know okay well this is
definitely happening you can tell that's
what it is yeah there's no question yeah
right after those photos of Gigi and um
uh and Maddie went viral on Twitter
that's when we were hit with pop base
they were photographed heading to her
Nashville condo boom done oh the condo
yes the condo okay Matt and then I hope
you got old other idiots moved up I know
Joe he's in London
um and then the next one I just included
one of our own tweeted something very
funny I thought
yeah
oh yes
hold the pump
is that actually him though like I know
it's a joke but like it
it is wait that's the hold on I didn't
even pay attention to the Post
I'm a [__] wait I'm not hating but how
can you tell I know it looks like The
Grudge or something that's Smoking Gun
right there yeah I know that yeah it's a
Smoking Gun right there I know that neck
that's a ghost that's not Matt Healy we
all know that's Matt Healy that's an orb
bro yeah that's called Linda man yeah
that's a good one did someone covering
their face is it I can't tell at all
it's just kind of weird like what are we
supposed to be taking away from these
photos it's like a head crab it's a
Rorschach test that's what it is what do
you see here I don't even see a human
figure boy this is real they published
it yeah yeah yeah and it's big news yeah
I saw it and I was like okay confirmed
37 million views on the stream yo you
know it's giving Prince Philip kind of
like you know the classic photo when
he's like a corpse in the car yeah yeah
a little bit
I am a little bit confused how that's
him I don't even see a human figure wait
it's he's no he's he's looking it's like
he's looking at it he's like looking at
her yeah away from the window he's
facing her that's like his ear and he
has something it looks like can you send
me this photo so I can zoom in because I
can't do it also this is Twitter after
Twitter compression and you know Twitter
has had some bad months uh with like
reducing qualitation like that here is a
picture here's a picture of uh people
saying that's not real
in the chat AI generated
oh god dude
hold on is this real is this what he
really looks like or looked like
rest in peace that's when he takes the
ring off
please don't ever let me get old
well I mean he is dead there no I know
they're just rolling him around oh he's
dead no
it looks like he's stuck on a roller
coaster he's just [__] He's terrified
all the time Shell Shocked dude
[Music]
[__] me dude
this is the single scariest photo I've
ever seen in my life
haunting
I can't get over it
[__] this is from him from leaving the
hospital apparently too
all right so I got a close-up of the
photo
okay here's a close-up
here's Matt Healy
how old was he in this photo
gotta be over a hundred right
decomposing before death
that's what it looks like
all right did you send me a close-up of
this one I did it's above the
Prince photo
here it is here it is
okay interesting so here's one of them
I'm gonna get a real close-up so the
thing is you can clearly make up Taylor
and you can clearly make out magic oh I
see I see it yeah he's going like this I
see
I see
no here's his hand hi Maddie watch and
here's his the profile of his face his
nose
chin neck you see that Dan no you don't
Sideburn I see the Sideburn I'm sorry
I'm not trying to hate I don't see no
he's there he's there well you guys are
then you know what you have to relax
your eyes and let them cry it's like one
of those
hold on I I just realized I'm on I'm on
low latency mode let me uh let me
sharpen this no I totally see it here's
his Sideburn
um
his arm
and they're like two seconds away from
kissing right guys no yeah that's not
what it is a faceless man no no no yeah
it's just a profile and Slender Man from
here here's his hair
Sideburn ear okay yes fist arm no you
see it neck jaw right here here's the
job
okay that's what I was seeing what Zach
was talking about I didn't even see that
this right here
like very outfit
nightmare no yeah I don't see that one
no I see
[Laughter]
um
pulling up to a Nashville apartment I
don't know I've got we have uh I did
some enhancements yeah cam sent an HD
photo yeah enhanced yeah so it's more
clear here
there he is Maddie Healey age 30. you
see it now
they're so cute together right you might
be a little old for [__] I don't know
he's only 34.
I 100 see it yeah he's there thank God
you said that yeah I see it he's in
there
but yeah that would be happening to be
in there
that's what we have as of last night
that's the whole thing yep
until until uh they make their nest
their next move
hmm I see it now I actually see it in
this photo now
okay
do we want to go back and see if maybe
uh we think that they are mouthing the
same thing or are we giving up I I
believe it okay after seeing all that
after seeing it I believe it
100 percent
thank you so much thank you so much
the only question is is he really Taylor
Swift Worthy
well yeah that is that is a very
important question I don't know
who is what yeah people thought Joe
that's why people were so you don't have
a job
oh yeah he did when they started dating
that dude's like a bachelor material
they go in there with no [__] job
they're just handsome that's their
credentials no she needs a she needs a
full
y
complex experienced
person you know what I mean
he has no pizza experience
Nick Cannon said in an interview
recently he wanted her to be the next uh
baby mama of his that was on Howard I
think he was being uh
playful with them he was uh John Mayer
she dated John Mayer she did she has a
song called Dear John very good he's
known to be a douche right yeah and he
was a lot older than her when they dated
gross
one of the lyrics is don't you think 19
was too young
and yeah speak now is her next fall
album so we're about to go forward on
John Mayer is she still [__] on him
um I mean
no but like she will be like remember
when everyone was going hard on Jake
Gyllenhaal when read Vault uh came out
oh my God
I'm excited okay hold on how old was he
when she was 19.
that's what I need to know he was 32.
yikes
John Mayer dated Swift Back In December
2009 inspiring her breakup Anthem Dear
John I love that she names him too yeah
I had a lot of feelings about being the
subject of an inflammatory song
following the demise of their
relationship he discussed the
humiliating experience in Rolling Stones
it made me feel terrible because I
didn't deserve it oh shut up you're
gonna be a little baby about it
let the 19 year old write her music
chill out that's what you get bro you
wanted to you wanted to you know date
the the cool 19 year old rock star
it's on you brother I'm pretty good at
taking accountability now and I never
did anything to deserve that it was a
really loud thing for her to do [__]
next
I never got an email was she gonna email
you I never got a phone call I was
really caught off guard and really
humiliated me at the time good it sounds
like you need to be taken down a peg to
the world of favorite John Mayer
yeah you know why they call him John
Mayer
because he's no bucket required because
he's like of Mayor a horse
I appreciate where you're going with
that
I tried you know what I mean
I mean how would you feel at the lowest
you've been someone kicked you even
lower
probably like uh John Mayer
there it is
Joe Jonas
okay
uh dreamy Joe Jonas we are calling him
of Joe Jonas brother's Fame dated Swift
in 2008 the pair had tumultuous breakup
that inspired a cringe-worthy YouTube
video excuse me I'm clicking that
oh my God there's so much lore I love
this [__]
Taylor Swift's message to Joe Jonas 6.5
14 years ago damn all right ancient
history
see this one even comes
well here let me put on the captions oh
[__]
all right so just missing them unmute it
but not too loud you know what I mean
was it the phone break up with other
dolls to break up with other dolls
okay I wouldn't say it's that cringe
were they it's not that crazy
uh let's see and Swift's most
problematic song better than revenge
which was reportedly about Jonas
ex-girlfriend Camilla Bell
Jonas shared his thoughts about the
split I never cheated on a girlfriend
it might make someone feel better to
assume a reply I've been unfaithful but
it is simply not true maybe there was a
reason for a breakup
maybe the heart moved on
maybe you were there you tell me maybe
perhaps feelings changed perhaps you
were there
I think they may have made up since then
she was on Ellen said that she regretted
putting him on blast
that's good
we stand the Jonas Brothers I believe is
that right I think so yeah yeah
I am uh I am truly saddened that
anything I would potentially well okay
so this one's not that juicy but shout
out Calvin Harris this is the guy
he accused her PR team of trying to make
him look bad and Swift went public with
writing credits for Harris and Rihanna's
hit
seems to me that dating Taylor Swift is
a little bit of a
liability
in terms of
that like
there's a pretty good chance she's gonna
put you on blast at the end of that well
don't do her wrong you know what I mean
I'm just saying be good if you if you're
gonna step in the room with Taylor you
better not [__] wrong her yeah
I'm great let me think about it don't
even [__] think about it
we're talking to you Matty Healy don't
try anything crazy
oh he's gonna get it worse than anyone I
can tell he's gonna [__] this up
we'll see he's gonna get a whole album
called Maddie Healy kill yourself or
something
[Music]
okay Calvin
they Swatch she dated Harry Styles very
short
and that's odd
Tom Hiddleston I remember this
look kind of weird he's old as [__] 42
Old idiot loser
dumbass [__] idiot dumbass oh old
[__] what she dated the [__]
werewolf from yeah they were in
Valentine's Day the movie together
that's uh Jacob
yeah she dated the werewolf yes you know
his uh wife's name is Taylor Lautner
Taylor Lautner's wife
yo he's from Grand Rapids Michigan what
I find this funny that she dated him I
don't know why he's like a living meme
they date in 2009
however uh Michelle managed to get a
reaction out of Lautner regarding the
song she wrote a song about his ass too
huh
He's Back to December about him
that's according to this Michelle you
dated Taylor Swift I remember that
that's hilarious he said should we talk
about it no I I don't know why you guys
want to talk about it didn't she write a
song about you that's what she does she
writes songs oh he's keeping it he's he
knows who's keeping it tight yeah not
giving her another any more material for
another song
Jake Gyllenhaal
also 42 loser idiot old as [__] Prince
Charles looking ass
uh Gyllenhaal's been tight-lipped about
his time with Swift
Factor an awkward interview the guardian
villain Hall was markedly less chatty by
the situation I think when you're in a
relationship you're constantly screwed
now as your friends are scrutinized but
at that point he stopped talking
and the interviewer quickly changed the
subject oh wow they bailed him out
the interview asked if you lost your
legs in real life do you think Taylor
Swift would write a song about it like a
country song the [__] that's a weird
question
for me or about it for you like a
country song
that is a weird ass question insane
question
so that's all of them I guess
yeah
okay shout out
all the X's out there
very good
well how long we've been going Dano
uh two hours and 46 minutes
let's talk about the hour mark dubrick
dubrick
he's one of those guys I'm just like
whatever dude but this is quite quite
scummy he's um
he's now switched to streaming on Kik
the streaming website the train wreck
and all these guys made just so that
they could continue to show gambling
[Music]
online
here's dubrick right now doing a live
stream of him gambling
on stake of course
and I will say this video has 520 views
that's not a lot
this is dubrick and I saw it live you
only had like 4 000 views too
[Music]
that's not a lot man
that couldn't have been a good Roi for
them man
I'm sorry I'm moving that to 32. I just
took off 28. all right here we go good
that was good he just said crushing it
he just said
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
14. that's okay he is such a scumbag for
doing this I bet you're just like
everybody else sorry
now what do we do it's just the
shittiest thing in the world he has a he
has a track record of like exploiting
his young fans now I think like the
puzzle the puzzles giveaways
[__] gambling like he has probably
some of the youngest fans on YouTube and
he's doing all this [__] [__]
Shameless I think since he
got
canceled and lost all his opportunities
he uh is just trying to get the bag you
know yeah
although the puzzle was before his
cancellation
right
[__] me man I wish I didn't care about
anything you know much money we could
make doing this
we can make so much money doing this
dumb [__]
you just have to not give a [__] about
anything
maybe it's time to put the morals aside
Ethan
main love will be there one day
your dreams fell out one day
I mean it's a nice it's a lofty dream
why not get the bag
no
is there like a promo code on here use
code dubrick for
free deposit bonus
dubrick
fine 136 you know what we can do with
this [__] yeah yeah three grand
good thing good game everybody
crash
good game
look at all these idiots they sit there
unpaid just for the chance to get some
David morsels it's a little bit of test
of taste of David plow
500 people watch this VOD look at these
[__]
Monkeys dance
for a drop a drop of clout
[Music]
in a desert one drop is all they need
you know anyone watch Demon Slayer it's
like just one drop of
muzen's blood
never seen that one is it good the new
Season's happening it's really good
grumpy
really good
can't drop me
[Music]
foreign
oh yeah there is 2500 giveaway at the
end of stream yeah
here let's catch that kind of low don't
you think yeah that's probably just what
steak gave him
you know what I mean
yeah
let's see it
where'd it go
roll it God damn steak your website's
[__]
it's flipped roll it
all right
I'm spinning all right let's see it yeah
that's like those tick tocks where they
have like people playing with like clay
and then there's also someone talking oh
yeah like they're showing the GTA and
the podcast the train jumping game
Subway Surfers Subway Surfers Subway
Surfer okay okay Reddit post Jason tell
Jason to stop eating oh no
hahaha
I'm not kidding you
I think I'm doing one tomorrow I I have
one I know
I know but I know
any more info on it but I really think
I'm doing a Tesla giveaway I have one
ready what about the 2500 bed I've been
waiting to do this one and I think about
it
[Music]
this is literally his personality it's
just giveaway testless
what do you do I give I'm Tesla giveaway
guy
oh that's right but like what do you do
like what kind of content you make I did
a giveaway Tesla giveaways
like everyone always goes look for AC
everyone goes
where's my Tesla so I've really wanted
to do another one it's gonna be on
Instagram and I don't want to give away
any more info
um but it'll be fun oh and obviously if
you don't want the Tesla I don't know if
I'm gonna do it tomorrow so it could be
tomorrow in the next two weeks but if
you don't want to Tesla you can always
it's like 35 000 instead of the car
he's referring to the I show speed and
him did a giveaway of a bunch of Teslas
oh what was that a week ago
I don't know I heard some drama about it
too
um not too much about it we're giving
away five Teslas to anyone that signs up
for Herbalife
and the top seller Herbalife will get
here it is I'm actually curious now
how did I show speed end up in all this
weird [__] now like what the [__] look
at this
[__] why what the [__]
[Music]
this is stupid bro what the [__] you
have 10 Teslas in your driveway
so what's the game I want to know about
this he says all you have to do is share
this post your story tag a friend in the
comments and download the app work ninja
that's the game
what's the app called work Ninja
work Ninja
and uh what was interesting with this is
that there's a terms of conditions uh in
that post and apparently you don't
because there's like a legal things when
you do giveaways you don't have to do
those steps
to to enter the giveaway you just have
to email them right
here
everybody when you see me in person
guys so you can stop asking me about it
when you see me in person I'm here with
speed and today we're doing a Tesla
giveaway except this time we got 10 of
them so go check it out and good luck
sick uh work ninja is an AI writer uses
artificial intelligence to write essays
research papers and more bro chat EVT do
that for free I pay five dollars a month
for that she has better than work ninja
cool stuff right it's not free but how
much is work Ninja let's see bro Morgan
what's the chance that work now I like
that it's just explicitly advertised
he's like cheating on homework I knew it
was it had to be something a little
weird
you know
work ninjas allows you to complete any
essay within 30 seconds written
plagiarism free
I'd like to test that theory actually
how much is it to buy it I want to test
that [__] right now well let's see sign
up
and also make sure in your store and
stuff so we get entered right I could
win a Tesla
how can they tell if you downloaded the
app by the way they go restore it right
leave a comment and download the app to
be eligible how do they know if you
download that
how
explain it to me
it might be too late Dan I see that
David's face timing the winners on his
story right now [__] yeah [__] during
the promotional period entrance must
either download And subscribe to the
work Ninja app and utilize the app to
create at least one piece of content
or send an email with your name address
email and phone number and request enter
me in the Workman jump
X stobric and Watson's Sweepstake ain't
no way anybody emailing that's winning
um I want to get on work ninja right now
I needed to write me an essay
I want to compare it to chat gdp4 which
is going to [__] work ninja in that in
the uh
a place where you might get a prostate
exam
what's up with the prostate exam do we
have any uh motion on that one
Elena's trying to find a doctor we uh
we found uh what we thought was a good
lead and
um they all said no oh man it was like
multiple doctors too and if there's any
MDS in the audience
and you want to lose your job
we've already got one doctor fired uh
email us
maybe he could do it yeah I mean he's
got nothing to lose although he I don't
know that he's CR if he sells his
credentials just give me a dude finger
in my [__]
[Laughter]
I think that's just assault at that
point
someone's yeah there's no shot that that
website doesn't just use the GP the gbt
API
yeah definitely does what uh what do you
want an essay about I'm in you're in
Kick Niche or study Ninja
whatever the [__] work ninja okay ask
for an essay about how to pass a AI
check
you know what I mean and Dan you asked
chat gbt
say this
write me an essay about how to avoid AI
detection
in an AI written essay
and in the essay
make it so it would pass an AI
detection test
you got that we're going to test them
both in the AI test
let's see
it should be literally identical
I got the AI detector up
how much money do these [__] weirdos
have
just like some stupid little schemey app
to cheat on your homework
and they've got
they just dropped like a million bucks
on some stupid Instagram posts for
dubrick
is that weird I bet I bet there's crazy
money in AI right now like a bunch of
Angel Investors just investing in random
[__] it's like the internet bubble
because there's only like two or three
like high level sophisticated AI chat
bots so they're all going to be using
the same
technology
yeah it's definitely using shaji Patia
or um API
all right so av's first up this is
this is what it wait how do I open this
baby
I don't know why it why pasted it the
[__] send a text what the hell it's
because it's too long oh is this because
is this what is supposed to turn into
school
so here's what I got from Ninja
homework cheating Ninja
work ninja AI essays can a work ninja
cheater AI essays can be difficult task
for many writers
with the increase of AI tools and
automated writing and Grading it is
important to consider how to avoid them
when writing
the first step is to understand how AI
tools work
this doesn't seem like it's written very
good
Let's do an AI detection test
there we go guys
[__] a I texted with me protected it
wow come on dobrik you really are you
really promoting this [__] though brick
and then loves that one from chat gbt oh
99 sure that this [__] is lame generated
GPS
so here's one from chat ggp4 right love
this is four
all right because that's the that's the
one I [__] with oh yeah
you know what I mean
all right here's the one from chat
cheese before my boy
you don't have to be buying any Teslas
[__] you can use the three number three
one for free
this I love how they title it this one's
already better look how it's formatted
title evading AI detection a
comprehensive Guide for Content
authenticity this one's already way
better
[Music]
introduction understanding detect okay
here we go come on chat you do before
come on come on
let's go
okay okay actually that's super
impressive that's the first time
that I've seen that
prompt
this is the first time for me
so there you go
and do you have to pay for that [__] I
do no I didn't have to pay for it
wait why I had to put in my phone number
that's it
what the [__] are they getting at they
spent ungodly amounts of money to get
people to go use an app to get your
phone number what the [__] you're gonna
have to use a pay probably when you use
it more yeah so yeah probably get a
couple of freebies it only lets you have
a certain amount of words but if you
want to go up I think there's yeah
there's pricing here uh how much is it
it's by tokens so it's like 200 tokens a
month for ten dollars dude why are they
doing tokens that's already so shady
ain't Chuck E cheese [__]
all right tell me the token price I'm
gonna send you a picture of it because
it's
you have to visualize it
God
David you're such a scumbag
all right here's our token uh base for
Ninja cheating scumbag.com
congrats you're getting ahead of your
writing let's see
so
you can't even have unlimited use fifty
dollars a month for 1500 tokens so
you're limited and how much you can use
it even at fifty dollars a month oh God
I need to write
600 essays this month
[Laughter]
well what does a token mean I I assume
each prompt is is a use so I doubt that
it's probably word based are you gonna
do
yeah no there's it's got to be what's a
token I'm a joke actually a lot of AIS
use this kind of system either words or
tokens
that's how the that's how the gbt API
work right actually buy buy every
using the API you need to buy every yeah
you need to pay for per per prompt are
you are you looking up what's a token
yeah it's not very clear okay I'm out of
free tokens
um
doesn't really specify so why what am I
supposed how am I supposed to know what
that means
if I'm paying 50 a month I get 1500
tokens what the [__] does that mean
David
look at this [__]
this is uh
the [__] you ran out of free tokens
but what okay 35 uh saving
but what is a token I don't know but
it's 35 off it's like yeah okay no to a
deal sign me up
well there you go uh
David dubrick's a piece of [__]
and he's promoting a more expensive and
far less
a good service for scamming your
homework
it's more than homework it could write
you a poem an article music yeah or even
a movie script
yeah
um here's the explanation from open ai's
website so this is their token
specifically uh one token equals
approximately four characters in English
or think of it as three quarters of a
word 100 tokens equals approximately 75
words oh that's expensive bro yeah what
a hundred wait wait wait say that again
bro our papers are longer than that yeah
they say like 1500 words equals
approximately 2048 tokens
and how many tokens did we get for 50 a
month 15. it was fifteen hundred and how
much do you spend on a 1500 word
uh 1500 word is 2 000 tokens over two
thousand so it's YouTube
it says over that for one essay yeah
seems pretty bad like a bad deal
you know what I don't think I'll be
getting uh word ninja after all okay
wait we just got I've changed my mind
we just got 25 free tokens because you
invited someone right oh no that's if
okay so guys use our link please bro I
need these tokens
please everybody
what a joke
cheaper you know what
it's a lot cheaper to just write the
essay myself
I think I might just do that not with
chat gdp4
chat cheat pt4 is [__] awesome dude
I live for it die for it bro I promote
it for free forever
one God
one God his name's Chad GPT
[Music]
thank you
but it's like meaningless anyways
because it didn't pass the [__] uh it
failed robot yeah it feels like 99 fail
yeah no matter how much you cost them
yeah
you're about to spend 60 a month for one
[__] essay
and then it fails 99 man Double's a
douche
hell no
fat L bro
oh wait a minute so that the tokens are
for the input so that's the amount of
words you can prompt it with not how
many words it spits out
I'm reading further in this article what
I'm going to be thought of a piece of
words before the API can process the
prompts the input is broken down into
tokens right so that's the prompt
so I mean that's still pretty bad like
that is bad because why you would want
to be more it's not as bad but well the
economy of that is weird because you
want to be more specific but they're
enticing they're yeah so I mean the the
1500 tokens at least on chat GPT would
get you
as I don't know like about a thousand
words that you can prompt it with per
month
it's pretty bad
it was easier to just write the [__]
essay at that yeah watch when you run on
like short on tokens there's probably
some sort of slot
you gamble for more oh that's a good and
gamble yourself
if you can't afford 50 you can deposit
ten yeah and see if you can win some
tokens at our digital arcade
kick.com
all right well that's about it eh that's
about it eh
it's about enough of that so tomorrow
members members we will be live I will
be live at 3 P.M for all of our
beautiful gracious
supportive members who love love thank
you guys
we'll be seeing you tomorrow and on
Wednesday
if we can't find a doctor let's just
find a Craigslist guy and put him in a
white coat and have him
we got to get this done
oh my god dude oh my God he's down for
anything
he's a good guy let's ask him
trustworthy
yeah as long as you don't have those
Charles this King Charles fingers I'll
be fine man oh no
I'm getting prostate checked by Charles
no the king I couldn't deal
I'd be like yo is that your scepter or
your finger
so anyway we're back on Wednesday
members I'll see you tomorrow at three
thank you guys for being here we love
you we love you peace and love peace and
love
uh
uh oh we forgot to talk about ali London
was popping off on me
no no no no no no well
y'all want to talk about Ollie London
okay pulp what happened we forgot to
talk about Ole London what more is what
do you want to say about all you know
he's just he's coping about me still on
Twitter yeah I mean give me that now
last week too he's gonna be doing that
for a while
such a little [__] boy
[__] boy little [__] boy can you get
me that tweet it's a little [__]
[Music]
London we're getting tickets we'll get
we're we're getting getting tickets
yeah this is great we don't have the
button right now Dan
there's no button just just a friendly
reminder
just a friendly reminder he's just he's
gone he's popping off with all my
greatest hits actually declares war on
Catholics and says
something something the Vatican City
needs to be you know
I mean he said it
If this means down shutting down the
entire kayaks Jersey and B wording v c
and not the Viet Cong
already got her punishment for that one
sorry yeah I mean what do you want
Double Jeopardy bro yeah why is this man
who inside violence
it's not common law
Double Jeopardy is against common law
okay but it's funny we're in your
history look there there are definitely
things I've done and said that I'm
deeply ashamed of right and that I would
like
be embarrassed I get embarrassed every
time I see it and I'll apologize every
time I see it because it is genuinely
embarrassing and I feel ashamed that
that I that Don or said those things
but he's just doing my greatest hits bro
uh then he tweeted again he's trying to
get me demonetized from YouTube now you
believe this just because I embarrassed
him in a debate
he goes on he goes oh no far left Five
Guys Ethan Klein of H3 says he hopes
they're another Holocaust I was like man
shut up he brought that up in the debate
too yeah and I corrected him
I'm Jewish bro stop it stop it
why is this man peddling hate speech
allowed to monetize on YouTube
such a [__]
and now you're coping and trying to get
me demonetized listen to yourself Ollie
again greatest hits
YouTuber Ethan Klein issue positives if
Jesus was alive today he would execute
him with his own hands
this is my fave this is the one where I
was joking about and that's a banger I'd
spare him again because I'm a Jew and
the Jews killed Jesus according to them
this makes no sense Ollie that that's
what they were there to do you gotta you
gotta pick a lane bro Jesus was meant to
die or was he not meant to die
it's just a K-pop cartoon Ollie
is this
cute I always have my mouth open like
this like this
I always have I always do this on
children's uh I always do this on
children's lunch boxes
[Music]
I tried I don't know that's pretty good
it was yeah thank you
if Jesus was here I'd spear him give me
the hammered Spike I put him up there
I'd do it again
say it louder written back
oh then this one far left YouTuber Ethan
Connor issue podcast openly calling for
something something NRA
why is this man a letter to monetize I
mean this
I think I got a strike for all these
except the uh mods mods can somebody
please do something about this uh excuse
me mods Ethan's saying very upsetting I
am I am so free speech I'm so free
speech bro by the way you agree to come
on my show if you hate me and thought I
was a scumbag so much why the [__] do
you come talk to me he came to embarrass
you and he did Frank I guess so
boy is this allowed on YouTube what
just a cute cartoon Ethan I love you
Jesus anyway I'll be doing a live stream
later on The Daily wire about how to
systematically a genocide trans people
thank you
foreign
he's such a hateful little demon someone
in chat said he did his research after
going on the air right right right
big mistake there
um
but I but again of the all the things
I've said and done that I regret and
there are many these four I've never
seen someone choose these four and
attempt to embarrass me because I mean
frankly
I'm not embarrassing we got our
punishment yeah we already got in
trouble for him got a button
the content was removed by YouTube they
did their jobs
they went wrong smash that button you
know if even Crowder can come on here
and mock execute George Floyd
Ethan Ethan can say a few politically
and correct things that's a treat
[Laughter]
I agree that's a treat it's balanced
that's a treat
Ethan's not allowed to do this
yeah that's a pretty fire compilation
can you edit those all together Ollie so
I can post it on tick tock
maybe the fan cam do me a fan I mean you
know
thanks bro I appreciate that
people saying I lost a lot of weight
yeah you look skinny yes sir skinny
Legend
[Applause]
s
I don't know what do you guys
you look skinny
boy before you took the shirt off it was
transparent looked like you really lost
a lot weight we were like where is
oh
[Music]
get it shake it shake it baby oh yeah
there he goes Ollie's gonna clip this
out of context now again
he's showing too much skin mods
all right guys thanks to everyone for
being here
it's a Monday let's go get it
family strong oh uh
should uh mention Thursday
oh [__] this on
oh there's no leftovers this week Hassan
is traveling again living his best life
do you know where he's going are you
allowed to say
but I don't know maybe it's supposed to
be described or something I don't know I
I think he would have said if he didn't
want me to say anything right
maybe let's not I think don't say he's
traveling
and it sounds fun
so I uh so there'll be no show uh
there'll be no leftovers
um
this week
[Music]
but what I will be doing is doing a
three hour Mega compilation about ali
London
we'll do a three-hour special of us
screaming
Peppa
three hours of that and
[Music]
London
oh yeah a reminder before we go if
you're looking for something
uh ELO's vlog
huh Aila vlog
oh my God that thumbnail what the f
I didn't see that whoa what in that the
hecking dog
that is a thumbnail yo Ethan's wife's
doing only fans
I'm not gonna lie that was my suggestion
oh I did not seen that till now it's a
good thumbnail guys oh Queen
we love it
on the Ethan and Neil Channel yes yes
yes yes so
I think this is game all right but
somebody in the chat asks why do you
scream his name why do we scream his
name
why don't you funny
[Applause]
oh
what are you doing that oil and London
that's all the racket then
you're making me proper miffed
all right guys we'll see you uh on
Wednesday fans tomorrow have a great
night everybody
[Music]
eBay upon you
foreign